robert habeck vorliegt da ist abgestimmt
natürlich auch mit anderen ressorts und
das hat durchaus die ein und andere
implikation gehabt gleich also wie
gesagt schon und wie sie gehört vor
allem auch die regierungserklärung dazu
es wird mit diskutiert werden in diesem
zusammenhang auch der bericht der
jahresbericht der wirtschaftsweisen
zudem anträge aus der afg und aus der
linksfraktion und es gibt aber auch ich
wenn ich jetzt das richtig parat habe
auch einen entschließungsantrag der
unionsfraktion dazu also jede menge zu
diskutieren heute morgen um 9 aber ein
paar eckpunkte zumindest waren wir
vorher schon erörtern und ich freue mich
dass dazu da sind gesine lötzsch die
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
linksfraktion ihnen einen schönen guten
morgen und dieter janitschek ist der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen der titel
der regierungserklärung nicht des
jahreswirtschaftsberichts titel der
regierungserklärung ist transformation
gestalten ordnungsrahmen klima gerecht
fortentwickeln herr janitschek das
klingt ein bisschen weit reichend aber
auch ein wenig sperrig sagen sie uns mal
ganz anschaulich worum es geht und was
das zentrale anliegen dieses
jahreswirtschaftsberichts ist ja die
ziele sind ja auch weit reichend wir
wollen die soziale marktwirtschaft
erweitern zu einer sozial ökologischen
marktwirtschaft dh den klimaschutz mit
der wirtschaft verbinden und vorteile
für beide seiten generieren und dafür
wollen wir große investitionen
voranbringen 60 milliarden euro in dem
energie und klima vor der jetzt
aufgelegt wurde und das heißt wir geben
ein signal für die unternehmen aber auch
für die verbraucher dass wir jetzt
marode infrastrukturen sei es im bereich
der öffentlichen daseinsvorsorge aber
insbesondere auch was industrie und den
wandel richtung klimaneutralität geht
voran bringen signale wie ich gestern
auch noch mal nachgefragt habe die die
wirtschaft dringlich erwartet auch was
wir was die investitionen angeht und
überhaupt auch planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren und ähnliches
rolle die union sagt das sei kein
jahreswirtschaftsbericht sondern ein
weiterer nachhaltigkeitsbericht alle
inhalte würden ökologischen zielen
untergeordnet was ihre bewertung über
details reden wir noch im laufe der
nächsten zehn minuten also ich glaube
das hauptproblem ist dass man ja von
einer sozialen marktwirtschaft zu einer
sozialen ökologischen übergehen will und
sich die frage stellen muss ob soziale
marktwirtschaft für viele menschen in
unserem land überhaupt noch erlebbar ist
wir haben jetzt als ergebnis der handel
aber auch der entwicklung vorjahr eine
enorme verteilungs krise viele menschen
haben geringe einkommen minijobber mini
rentner und ohne diese verteilungs krise
zu lösen also ohne mehr sozialer
gerechtigkeit ohne mehr
verteilungsgerechtigkeit werden wir auch
die ökologische krise nicht lösen also
zu viel ökologie als ziel drin soziales
oder lou wie man muss das verbinden man
kann die ökologische krise nicht lösen
wenn man die soziale krise nicht löst
verbinden sie es nicht hinreichend ich
werde gleich mal fortführen noch weil es
gehe ja nicht nur das wachstums
kriterium eine entscheidende rolle
spielen also das wachstums kriterium wie
sich wiederfindet dem
bruttoinlandsprodukt janitschek sondern
es sollen weitere faktoren dazu kommen
also sogenannte wohlfahrts und
nachhaltigkeitsindikatoren auch wieder
so begriffen wo man erst mal ein
bisschen im nachfassen muss was wofür
steht das eigentlich helfen sie uns ja
wir wollen schon was verändern das heißt
auch die art und weise wie wir wohlstand
messen wollen wir verändern dh sie haben
zu recht gesagt soziale indikatoren
müssen einer wohlfahrts oder einer
wohlstands messung auch wirklich
sichtbar sein die frage der sozialen
ungleichheit der herkunft bildung aber
eben auch der ökologische fußabdruck das
probieren wir jetzt zum ersten mal das
wird auch noch ausgebaut und erweitert
in diesem jahreswirtschaftsbericht aber
natürlich geht es auch im kern glanztat
jetzt um die frage wie geht es weiter
mit der industrie mit ihren lieferketten
mit den corona helfen all das wird auch
in der debatte nach in der große rolle
spielen da hätte ich trotzdem gerne noch
mal ein bisschen konkreter erläutert
bislang sagen wir bruttoinlandsprodukt
bemisst sich an den erbrachten
dienstleistungen an den hergestellten
gütern und waren jetzt wollen sie andere
faktoren touch funktion sie haben ein
bisschen angedeutet sagen sie das noch
mal konkreter und sagen sie mal vor
allem wie daraus eine sogenannte
kenngröße entstehen soll wie das
bruttoinlandsprodukt ja auch genannt
wird nachdem der politik gemacht wird
das bruttoinlandsprodukt bleibt ihr
erhalten auch als kenngröße das ist auch
für die ökonomen auch für uns wichtig
dass wir einfach wissen ist der güter
umlauf welche entwicklung gibt es auf
verschiedenen sektor märkten auf der
anderen seite haben wir aber in der
vergangenheit eine situation gehabt wo
wachstum nicht automatisch bedeutet hat
dass menschen
sozial besser abgesichert waren
beispielsweise dass jobs auch
entsprechende löhne hatten dass menschen
in jobs kamen die mit denen sie auch
leben konnten wurde das im grunde das
was rot ja auch angela sieht auch
wahrscheinlich haben wir in
einzelbereichen dann auch differenzen
wie weit man gehen muss und natürlich
die große frage das ist das
bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat beim
klimaschutz muss jetzt eine regierung
auch in der wirtschaftspolitik bei den
investitionen handeln weil wir das
verbinden müssen das heißt
wirtschaftliches handeln muss auch
nachhaltigkeit implizieren und das muss
ich jetzt konsequent in seinem
jahreswirtschaftsbericht auch
wiederfinden
was fehlt er macht die das spektrum wird
er deutlich erweitert wird die frage ist
nur ist es sind das schöne beschreibung
ist es kosmetik oder ist es wirklich
handeln fragen wie normal und für mich
ist die entscheidende frage dass ich
wirklich die verteilungs krise auch dass
die voest wird und wir haben ja eine
situation dass in unserem land das
einkommen die vermögen ungeheuer
ungleich verteilt sind 45 deutsche
besitzen so viel wie die gesamte ärmere
hälfte der bevölkerung und diese
verteilungs krise hängt natürlich auch
die wirtschaftliche entwicklung und die
weniger leute ein gutes einkommen haben
desto mehr können sie zum beispiel auch
in der binnennachfrage dazu beitragen
dass sich die wirtschaft weiter
entwickelt und wir sehen auch was den
ökologischen fußabdruck betrifft das ist
im augenblick noch sehr sehr ungerecht
zugeht denn menschen mit dem geringsten
einkommen haben auch den kleinsten
ökologischen fußabdruck müssen aber hohe
kosten tragen wir haben jetzt die
situation dass die energiepreise enorm
gestiegen sind und da ist das wichtigste
aus meiner sicht dass wir wieder zu
einer staatlichen preiskontrolle kommen
natürlich kann muss man kurzfristig
ausgleichen durch zuschüsse für die
ernst nie das nicht finanzieren können
aber das darf nicht zu einer weiteren
umverteilung auf kosten der
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler
führen sondern da brauchen wir wirklich
endlich wieder preis deckelung und
staatliche energiekunden preiskontrolle
gerne direkt dazu
also wir sind sehr skeptisch was jetzt
eine preis steuerung auf den
energiemärkten angeht sehr wohl haben
wir maßnahmen ergriffen zum beispiel was
ist das thema wohngeld angeht für
wohngeldbezieher innen dass wir dort
auch eingegriffen haben im sinne von
ersten zahlungen und die auch notwendig
sind hier im sozialen ausgleich zu
schaffen die eeg-umlage wird entweder
zum ersten ersten 2023 oder vielleicht
sogar schon früher abgeschafft das heißt
sie wird eine senkung des strompreises
geben davon werden auch verbraucher
profitieren und wir haben als grüne
fraktion ja auch den vorschlag
unterbreitet ein klima geld einzuführen
dh insbesondere dann auch dass die
ärmeren in der gesellschaft und auch
davon profitieren dass wir das geld was
wir auf der co2 seite einnehmen das ist
ja auch da dass wir das zurückgeben was
ist richtig das muss jetzt auch kommen
da muss jetzt auch gehandelt werden in
den nächsten monaten und jahren der
soziale und ökologische umbau das muss
einhergehen und das darf nicht
gegeneinander laufen die abschaffung der
umlage das begrüßen wir natürlich aber
dann verbinden wir natürlich die
forderung damit dass
abgesichert werden muss dass die großen
energiekonzernen keinen mitnahmeeffekt
haben und sagen da stecken wir uns jetzt
ein und deshalb unsere forderung
natürlich nach einer wiedereinführung
der staatlichen preiskontrolle anders
wird es nicht funktionieren
jetzt möchte ich werde dann
die frage die ich tatsächlich auch hatte
und diese hier angesprochen haben wird
das geht es dann tatsächlich irgendwie
zugunsten dann auch der verbrauch ein
verbraucher aus da haben wir eine
vergangenheit die erfahrung gemacht dass
das nicht automatisch der fall gewesen
sind auch wenn der staat macht gegeben
hat bei bei steuern und abgaben haben
dass die unternehmen trotzdem einen
behalten und unser eine hatte nichts
davon das ist der eine punkt wohl zurück
wo sie noch mal ein bisschen klarheit
schaffen könnten und der andere ist wie
konkret ist es denn überhaupt das ganze
vorhaben dass diese die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage tatsächlich vorzuziehen ich
höre das auch natürlich immer aber es
passt ja jetzt gerade auch in die in die
preissteigerung debatte und die
steigenden energiepreise aber wie
konkret arbeiten sie da eigentlich dran
auch als koalition man muss ein bisschen
differenzieren was die verbraucherinnen
verbraucher insbesondere aus ärmeren
haushalten brauchen und ich sag jetzt
mal auch ein bisschen flapsig was die
industrie uns erzählt was sie braucht
nicht alle vorschläge aus der lobbyisten
zum der muss man eins zu eins umsetzen
insofern ist es auch ein bisschen mehr
marktwirtschaft wagen in dem punkt zu
sagen ja wir brauchen entlastungen für
die menschen die es brauchen aber wir
brauchen nicht zwingend in jeder
erhöhung von energiepreis situationen da
eine entlastung für breite teile auch
der wirtschaft oder auch des gehobenen
mittelstandes und da muss man
unterscheiden weil wenn wir jetzt sofort
sehr viel geld ausgeben in der breite
dann fehlt dass das am ende am anderen
ende so das ist die diskussion die eeg
umlage werden wir abschaffen das ist
vereinbart im koalitionsvertrag frage
ist nur noch der stichtag und wann das
überhaupt geht da gibt's nämlich auch
vorlagen wer das klima geld was ich
angesprochen das hat mich nicht
vereinbart wird es halt nicht so gut wie
wie konkret ist eigentlich ist und dass
es tatsächlich vorgezogen wird und wie
konkret daran gearbeitet wird das ist
weiß ich nicht mitte des jahres so da
waren noch immer was fast ins auge ich
persönlich und auch für meine fraktion
bin zurückhaltend dass wir da jetzt ein
sehr schnellen schritt gehen weil wenn
wir jetzt die eeg-umlage sehr früh
abschaffen dann heißt das auch dass wir
aus hat er ist dann ja einige milliarden
weniger haben dann zehn teams werden
bitte sehen ungefähr habe ich gelesen ja
also die frage wird sein was wir wollen
und ich habe einen schwerpunkt auf das
thema klima geld das wir auch
artikulieren werden innerhalb der
koalition zu sagen wir wollen jetzt
gezielt entlasten wir wollen die
eeg-umlage abschaffen aber dann bitte in
einem gemeinsamen schritt zum ersten
ersten 2023 haushalt ist ein gutes
stichwort da ist mir ja wirklich sehr
schwer im magen und fliegt mir immer
noch schwer im magen dass sich die fdp
sehr gut durchgesetzt hat also die
schuldenbremse ist ja etwas was
ökonomisch völlig unsinnig ist und
natürlich auch die öffentlichen
investitionen hemd und die grünen haben
ja vor der wahl immer gesagt also so
geht das mit der schuldenbremse nicht
weiter jetzt hat sich erstmal die fdp
durchgesetzt mit herrn lindner und ich
kann die grünen und natürlich auch die
spd jetzt steht er in grüner neben mir
nur auffordern sich das nicht
weiterbilden zu lassen denn wir haben ja
gesehen dass wir öffentliche
investitionen brauchen und wenn wir
nicht genug einnahmen haben dann können
wir diese öffentlichen investitionen
noch nicht realisieren und was die
unternehmen betrifft ist mir auch ganz
wichtig darauf hinzuwirken dass die
unternehmen selber investieren die
investitionen die die unternehmen
tätigen sind wirklich immer weiter
abgesunken die gewinne werden nicht mehr
so investiert wie vielleicht vor 25
jahren sondern es gibt ausschüttung und
das ist finde ich nicht in dem er an
dieser situation
die forderung aus der industrie sie
haben das ja auch angesprochen und dass
man nicht jeder folgen kann aber ich
glaube hier muss man viel strikter
vorgehen und unternehmens
steuersenkungen wie sie herr lindner ins
auge gefasst hat die sind überhaupt
nicht hinnehmbar und da sollten die
grünen auch aus den fehlern ihrer ersten
regierungszeit mit gerd schröder lernen
denn damals wurden die
unternehmenssteuern so gesenkt und
darunter leiden wir heute noch wir
können oder wir müssen den grünen sogar
fragen wie viel grün oder wie viel
weniger grün denn in diesem
tatsächlichen jahreswirtschaftsbericht
noch drin ist im vergleich zu dem etwa
auf der im dezember bekanntgeworden ist
es hat einige formulierungen deutliche
formulierung änderungen gegeben habe
freundlicherweise die kolleginnen und
kollegen vom handelsblatt herausgefunden
beispielsweise was formulierung angeht
stadt ordnungsrahmen klima gerecht worte
entwickeln ist jetzt nur noch die rede
für sozial ökologische marktwirtschaft
also es gibt ja durchaus
unterschiedliche vorstellungen zwischen
ihnen und der fdp das wirtschafts
politik angeht sie ordnungspolitische
natürlich sehr viel sehr viel klarer die
fdp betonte liberale und betonten im
markt und da gibt es auch noch eine
formulierung die hier deutlich abweicht
im vergleich zur ersten version nämlich
dass der marktwirtschaftliche prozess
aus sich heraus zu einem sozial
ausgewogenen wachstum führt er ist
glaube ich auch nicht mehr drin also wie
viel haben sie preisgegeben ich glaube
das ist ein bericht der noch sehr klar
dass formuliert was wir jetzt auch in
der debatte nach er dann sagen werden
nämlich dass wir einen rahmen brauchen
der in richtung klimaschutz geht aber
eben auch soziale marktwirtschaft weiter
entwickelt dafür dass neue indikatoren
jetzt eingeführt werden um auch den
wohlstand neu zu messen und damit auch
signale bei bildung sozialer
ungleichheit zu geben und natürlich hat
man im ressort prinzip dann in der
abstimmung mit anderen immer auch noch
diskussionen zu berücksichtigen das ist
so aber sie können schon davon ausgehen
dass das heute ein sehr kraftvoller
aufschlag wird richtung
jahreswirtschaftsbericht richtung grüner
und auch soziale wirtschaftspolitik in
der zukunft gestrichen worden ist ersatz
scheitern der unsichtbaren hand des
marktes um zurückgenommen auch
generell ist eine generelle kritik am
wachstum im großen und ganzen also da
ist hat sich die fdp oder zumindest das
finanzministerium noch deutlich
durchgesetzt also robert hable kantig
formulieren das ja auch so dass wir
durchaus wachstum brauchen und zwar in
den bereichen wo das absolut notwendig
ist bei den erneuerbaren energien
brauchen wir ein drastisches wachstum
in der zukunft ziele zu erreichen wir
werden höheren stromverbrauch haben das
ist alles definiert also ist die
wachstums debatte insofern abstrakt dass
es doch darum gehen muss dass der
ressourcenverbrauch absinkt aber
gleichzeitig wie natürlich auch um für
soziale umverteilung dann entsprechende
mittel zu haben die mittel auch
generieren müssen unter dieses prinzip
bleibt auch erhalten aber wir wollen den
wachstumsbegriff erweitern um die frage
es muss verträglich seien in richtung
klimaschutz und es muss vor allem
verträglich seien in richtung soziale
gerechtigkeit die frage bleibt wie viele
selbst nicht durchsetzen können das
werden wir sehen und beobachten ich
hoffentlich aber sie dürfen sogar noch
mir fehlt natürlich völlig eine
perspektive für ostdeutschland das ist
überhaupt nicht berücksichtigt und wir
sind ja jetzt im wievielten jahr kann
man schon gar nicht mehr nach zählen der
deutschen einheit und da erwarte ich
dass da entschieden nachgebessert wird
und das ist natürlich auch eine
internationale frage denn die sanktionen
gegen russland treffen vor allen dingen
wirtschaftlich aus deutschland und hier
braucht es einen ausgleich und an dieser
stelle müssen wir dieses gespräch leider
beenden werden viele punkte gleich noch
mal wieder hören in der debatte frau
lötzsch vielen dank dass ich heute
morgen bei uns gewesen sind auch in der
janacek wir haben einiges gar nicht
besprechen können beispielsweise wenn
man die interessante diskussion über die
streichung von kfw förderung für
energetische sanieren und bauen gerade
in diesen tagen auch eine heikle debatte
dass das nicht zustande gekommen sind
sieben müssen reingehen und ich muss
langsam rüber geben ins plenum werke sie
dürfen also beide damit sie rechtzeitig
da sind denn wie gesagt um 9 beginnt
robert habeck hier seine
regierungserklärung zu eben diesem
jahreswirtschaftsbericht das ganze wird
wenn sie am anfang auch nicht dabei
gewesen sind sagt jetzt gerne nochmal in
verbindung diskutiert mit dem
jahresbericht der wirtschaftsweisen
außerdem liegen anträge vor und ich
glaube wenn ich das aus der ferne
richtig sicher ist der
bundestagspräsident ist als präsidentin
auch da ich gebe mal ganz schnell rein
in den plenarsaal
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
einen schönen guten morgen die sitzung
ist eröffnet
vor beginn in die tagesordnung habe ich
noch eine amtliche mitteilung zu machen
der ältestenrat ist gestern
einvernehmlich überein gekommen dass die
präsenzpflicht am dienstag der nächsten
sitzungswoche aufgehoben werden soll
nach paragraf 14 absatz 1 satz 2 des
abgeordnetengesetzes bestimme ich daher
dass der dienstag 15 februar
2022 nicht als sitzungstag gilt damit
entfällt insbesondere die pflicht sich
an diesem tag in die anwesenheitslisten
einzutragen
ich rufe auf den die tagesordnungspunkte
10 a und 10 a bis 10 c sowie
zusatzpunkte 4 und 5 abgabe einer
regierungserklärung durch den
bundesminister für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz mit dem titel für eine
sozial ökologische marktwirtschaft
transformation innovativ gestalten
jahreswirtschaftsbericht
2022 sowie die beratung des
jahreswirtschaftsberichtes
2022 der bundesregierung und des
jahresgutachtens 20
21 schrägstrich 2022 des
sachverständigenrates zur begutachtung
der gesamtwirtschaftlichen entwicklung
sowie beratung des antrags der fraktion
der afg mit dem titel
wachstumspotenziale in der daten
ökonomie gestalten entwicklungshemmnis
beseitigen und beratung des antrags der
fraktion die linke mit dem titel
europäisches greenwashing verhindern
einstufung von atomkraft als nachhaltige
technologie stoppen zu den
regierungschef zu der
regierungserklärung liegt ein
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen der
cdu/csu vor
für die aussprache im anschluss an die
regierungserklärung wurde eine dauer von
67 minuten beschlossen
das wort zur abgabe einer
regierungserklärung hat der
bundesminister für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz herr dr robert habeck
guten morgen frau präsidentin sich
gedanken und herren vielen dank für die
gelegenheit in diese debatte einzuführen
mit einer regierungserklärung zum
jahreswirtschaftsbericht
das vorgestern vom kabinett beschlossen
wurde und ich möchte an dieser stelle
noch einmal ausdrücklich den
sachverständigenrat für sein gutachten
danken es war ein fundus von
bezugsmöglichkeiten die den
jahreswirtschaftsbericht stark geprägt
haben also vielen dank die kollektive zu
sagen gute zusammenarbeit die situation
der deutschen wirtschaft ist mit um
parks zu beschreiben wir haben eine
robuste wirtschaft und einen stabilen
arbeitsmarkt wir haben in dem
jahreswirtschaftsbericht das ist ja vor
zwei tagen durch die medien gegangen
eine wachstumsprognose für dieses jahr
von 3,6 prozent etwas reduziert
gegenüber dem der herbstprojektion der
vorgänger bundesregierung was an der
korona pandemie liegt und wir erwarten
dann ein wachstum in 2023 von 2,3
prozent die dynamik kürzlich im ersten
quartal gebremst erst entwickeln was vor
allem an der krone pandemie und den
einschränkenden maßnahmen liegt aber
natürlich auch an der außenpolitischen
situation krisenhaften zeiten sind
häufig zeiten wo das investitionsklima
leidet wir erwarten dann aber dass das
vorkrisenniveau im zweiten quartal
dieses jahres erreicht wird die
inflation in diesem jahr wird nach
unserer prognose 3,3 prozent liegen und
dann im jahre 2023 sich um die zwei
prozent einpegeln also dem
inflationsziel der europäischen
zentralbank diese 3,3 prozent allerdings
sind das genauer aufzuschlüsseln oder
aufzudröseln die kerninflation liegt bei
2,4 prozent canon inflation also die
inflation ohne energiepreise und ohne
lebensmittel daraus kann man ablesen
dass die inflation in dem bereich
energie preis und lebensmittel der
besondere treiber ist und da gerade
haushalte mit niedrigerem einkommen mit
niedrigen einkommen in dem bereich
besonders viele konsumtive ausgaben
haben ist diese hohe inflationsrate eben
gerade für diese menschen eine besondere
belastung für alle auch für die
unternehmen auch für die wirtschaft aber
natürlich wird es da eine besondere
sozialpolitische abhängigkeit und
komponente die auch politisch
berücksichtigt und beantwortet werden
muss die arbeitslosigkeit wird sich
entsprechend dann
entsprechend der prognose von 5,7
prozent derzeit auf 5 1 prozent
reduzieren wir werden eine zunahme von
beschäftigung haben etwa 400.000
menschen werden zusätzlich in
erwerbsarbeit kommen und wir erwarten
einen anstieg der nettolöhne um 3,5
prozent soweit die daten des
wirtschaftsberichts der 130 seiten
umfasst und ein noch mehr anbietet aber
das sind wahrscheinlich die kerndaten
auch der debatte heute es lohnt
allerdings ein genauerer blick in das
umfeld in dem wir uns bewegen und da
beginnt dann ja die politik der
jahreswirtschaftsbericht ist vor allem
jahr einen instrumentenkasten will
analyse kasten zur findung der richtigen
instrumente wir sind in einer zeit die
viele unsicherheiten bietet und
bereithält für die menschen die
investieren wollen die unternehmen und
für das unternehmerische umfeld für die
kurzfristige situation die kommune
situation muss man feststellen dass mit
ungefähr 170 milliarden euro ist der
öffentlichen hand und dem start gelungen
ist die unternehmen in der überbrückung
zu halten aber es hat natürlich
konsequenzen
konsequenzen gezeitigt wir haben eine
geringe beschäftigungsdynamik gehabt und
wir haben vor allem eine ausbleibende
investitionstätigkeit in den letzten
jahren zu verzeichnen dazu kommen dann
eben die hohen preise für energie ich
habe es schon angesprochen die
sicherlich auch krisen abhängig sind und
viele einmaleffekte dieses jahres haben
aber auch die sprunghafte erholung der
wirtschaft im letzten jahr hat dann zu
den sprunghaften dynamiken vor allem
beim gaspreis geführt
mittelfristig sind andere
herausforderungen festzuhalten die man
jetzt schon sehr gut ablesen kann und
die der bericht auch auflistet wir
werden in eine dramatische fach und
arbeitskräfte lücke reinlaufen wenn wir
nicht mehr maßnahmen ergreifen mehr
qualifizieren aber auch mehr fachkräfte
zuwanderung organisieren das hat
das hätte dann konsequenzen für einen
erhöhten anstieg der sozialausgaben die
wiederum dann eine belastung für
wirtschaftliches wachstum
investitionstätigkeiten nach sich zögen
wir sind eine älter werdende
gesellschaft und wir sind eine
abnehmende der leben einer abnehmen
erwerbsbevölkerung das muss beantwortet
und bearbeitet werden so dass wir schon
für 2023 der bericht ist da vorsichtig
aber man kann es ab seht es kann sein
dass wir schon 2023 eine produktivitäts
rücke
münden die immer grösser wird dass es
also am ende mehr möglichkeiten gibt als
kapital und arbeit zur verfügung stehen
das droht dann aber auch sich im
jahrzehnt im nächsten jahrzehnt
fortzusetzen wenn wir nicht politische
maßnahmen dagegen ergreifen
mittelfristig weiterhin leidet die
deutsche wirtschaft unter einem
investitionsstau der größer geworden ist
in der akademie weil die investive decke
natürlich dünner geworden ist trotz der
überbrückungsmaßnahmen und der
stabilitäts- massen haben wir haben zu
lange planungszeiten in deutschland und
die genehmigungsverfahren da man zu lang
kurzfristig mittelfristig und
langfristig gilt für alle unternehmen
dass sie eine große herausforderung aber
auch natürlich große chancen haben durch
die umstellung auf eine co2 freie
wirtschaftsweise eine veränderte
wettbewerbssituation eine veränderte
globalen wettbewerbssituation kombiniert
sich damit wir müssen feststellen dass
die die globale wirtschaft wie sie die
letzten 30 jahre im grunde organisiert
war wir verlagern die gegen
produktionsweisen ins ausland veredeln
sie dann hier in europa und verkaufen
sie dann gewinnbringend an weltmarkt
sich dem ende zuneigt die vorherigen
bilder die produktionsländer haben
ebenfalls einen wachsenden wohlstand die
haben eine höhere nachfrage auch eine
höhere nachfrage nach
energie sodass wir gewärtigen müssen
dass wir eine rückkehr der geopolitik
haben wir sprachen darüber gestern schon
bei der außenpolitischen debatte die
dann sich aber auch wirtschaftspolitisch
so äußert dass es einen verstärkten
strategischen zugriff auf rohstoffe und
schlüsseltechnologien gibt insofern hat
sich tatsächlich gegenüber den
vorherigen jahreswirtschaftsberichtes
viel verändert es gibt eine andere
herausforderung situation die andere
politische instrumente erfordert bzw das
nachschärfen von politischen
instrumenten notwendig macht
man kann das im vergleich noch einmal
ganz gut sich vergegenwärtigen wir haben
bis 2015 die stärke der deutschen
wirtschaft nach der erholung von finanz-
und eurokrise vor allem durch den export
gesehen wir hatten einen
leistungsbilanzüberschuss das war der
höchste die wir bisher hatten in 2015
von 8,5 prozent
der leistungsbilanzüberschuss also
verhältnis von exporten zu importen ist
gleich geblieben in 2021 gegenüber dem
vorjahr blieben doch schwächer als 2015
wie ist der leistungsbilanzüberschuss
entstanden natürlich durch die starke
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der deutschen
wirtschaft aber eben auch durch eine
vergleichsweise schwache binnennachfrage
bei allem wachstum wir haben vor einem
auseinanderfallen von löningen gesehen
löhnen und einkommen gesehen so dass auf
der einen seite sich einen entwicklung
sektor aufgebaut hat auf der anderen
seite die exporte
gut gelaufen sind das hat die stärke der
deutschen wirtschaft in den zehn jahren
ausgemacht sie ist aber natürlich auch
wohne habe so ein wirtschaftsmodell ist
dann gegenüber einem veränderten
außenpolitischen umfeld und
rohstoffabhängigkeit eine energie
abhängigkeiten angreifbar so dass das
was die bundesregierung vor hat und was
der jahreswirtschaftsbericht mit dem
begriff sozial ökologische
marktwirtschaft skizziert tatsächlich
ein ausgewogeneres wachstumsmodell
darstellt ein ausgewogeneres
wachstumsmodell das auf eine höhere
binnennachfrage zielt das darauf setzt
dass wir die investitionstätigkeiten
hier im land hoch halten und damit
innovation und wachstum und auch
wettbewerbsfähigkeit schaffen und dass
wir stabile einkommenssituation hier in
europa und in deutschland haben
dass das schon auf einen ich würde sagen
okay weg ist zeigt der gini koeffizient
es gab hier eine gewisse debatte darüber
ob es richtig oder falsch ist dass der
jahreswirtschaftsbericht erweitert wurde
um mehrere und andere faktoren die davor
nicht drin waren die messung von
ungleichheit über den gini koeffizient
selbst ist erstmalig mit aufgenommen
worden da er kleiner wird sehen wir dass
das tatsächlich der weg ist den wir
einschlagen können wir müssen ihn nur
verstärken und energisch vor weiter
vorangehen die erholung in diesem jahr
die erholung in diesem jahr wird
folgerichtig
entsprechend vor allem durch einen
rückgang der sparquote und mehr
konsumtive aufgaben ausgaben der
menschen in diesem land getragen werden
wir haben in der korona pandemie
sicherlich auch durch die pandemie eine
erhöhung der sparquote auf 15 prozent
gehabt also von hundert euro die man hat
werden 15 prozent werden 15 euro
zurückgelegt das wird unserer prognose
nach sinken auf elf prozent entsprechend
werden dann mehr gelder ausgegeben
insgesamt muss man feststellen dass die
deutsche bevölkerung die höchsten
sparvermögen haben diese jemals hatte
sind auf 7,7 billionen euro angewiesen
wenn ein teil des geldes wieder
investiert wurde wenn es in der kultura
im restaurant an dienstleistungen
investiert werden würde dann
stabilisieren wir den aufschwung das
passiert natürlich
das passiert natürlich hoffentlich durch
das überwinden der korona pandemie ich
glaube keiner von uns kann das meer gut
leiden aber von alleine passiert ist
nicht das wäre dann verlässt sich das
wäre dann das zurücklehnen das
politische zurücklehnen sondern wir
brauchen und darauf richtet sich die
gesamte strategie der bundesregierung
eine stimulierung von innovations- und
wachstumsimpulsen und zwar sowohl
angebotsseitig wie nachfrageseitig dazu
hat die bundesregierung in dem
koalitionsvertrag und wir sind ja dabei
ist umzusetzen eine vielzahl von
maßnahmen identifiziert und entwickelt
so wollen wir den kapitalstock der
deutschen wirtschaft modernisieren durch
ein jahrzehnt der zukunftsinvestitionen
die investitionsquote in deutschland war
im vergleich unterdurchschnittlich wir
wollen sie über den durchschnitt der
europäischen union anheben wir wollen es
aber nicht als nationalen alleingang
oder als als wettbewerb mit anderen
partnern verstehen so dass wir wert
darauf legen dass gerade europäische
gemeinschaftsprojekte durchfinanziert
werden in der infrastruktur über alle
reden über wasserstoff es macht
natürlich sinn ein wasserstoff jetzt
netz jetzt europäisch insgesamt zu
planen und dann auch europäisch mit
einer regulatorisch und auch mit einer
finanzausstattung durch zu finanzieren
90 prozent
90 prozent aller investitionen sind
privat getragen um diese 90%
investitionstätigkeit auszulösen braucht
es aber manchmal öffentliche gelder
braucht es manchmal impulse braucht es
bürgschaften und sicherheiten so dass in
diesem risiko behafteten umfeld das sich
geziert habe der unternehmerische mut
die kreativität der wagemut der
wirtschaftlichen betätigung auch
flankiert wird und sich bestens und
besten gut entfalten kann wir werden
deswegen die beiträge der förderbanken
erhöhen wir werden karben concessions
oder nur komplett for difference is
einführen also geschäftsmodelle stützen
die erstmal in das risiko gehen im
gegenzug dann wenn das risiko
beherrschbar ist und sich diese
geschäftsmodelle bewährt haben dann
wiederum das geld das ihnen gegeben
wurde über einen preis der vorher
definiert wird zurückzahlen die
europäische union hat die gemeinsamen
geschäftsfelder von strategischen
interesse identifiziert die ips und
deutschland in seiner großen
wirtschaftskraft hat enorme gelder
bereit gestellt und diese dann auch hier
in deutschland zu entwickeln wir werden
also eine große investitionstätigkeit in
den nächsten jahren im rahmen dieser
einflüsse im bereich batterieproduktion
halbleiterfertigung und
wasserstoffproduktion wie verbrauch die
umstellung der industrie hier
wir wollen den staatlichen
wir wollen den öffentlichen
gesellschaften mehr möglichkeiten für
kreditermächtigungen geben indem wir
beispielsweise die
eigenkapitalausstattung ausstattung
erhöhen wir werden auch darüber wurde
nach schon besprochen über den klima und
transformations- von investitionen
unterstützen und damit dieses jahrzehnte
der zukunftsinvestition auslösen all das
ist bedingt durch die korona pandemie
die erhöhte investitionstätigkeit der
öffentlichen hand liegt daran dass die
unternehmerischen dass die kapitaldecke
teilweise dünn geworden ist und die
unterstützung dieser maßnahmen die wir
jetzt gewährleisten ist die antwort
darauf dass die krone pandemie eben
nicht vorbei ist wenn die inzidenz mal
wieder runter gehen sondern dass die
folgen nach 210 zweieinhalb jahren
wirtschaftlicher erlangung noch immer
gravierend sind ich gucke die jungen und
sage wer diesen zusammenhang in frage
stellt hat den jahreswirtschaftsbericht
nicht sorgfältig genug gelesen die
wirtschaft die wirtschaft
trägt sich in vielen teilen schon wieder
selbst aber bei weitem noch nicht in
allen und nach zweieinhalb jahren
wirtschaftlichen einschränkungen
abreißen der lieferketten ist es geboten
über den tag hinaus zu denken der tat
kann nicht mit der eröffnung von
restaurants enden der politische tag
kann es schon gar nicht vielleicht
überdenken sie noch einmal die
ankündigung gegen den klima und
transformations- von zu klagen sie
schaden damit tatsächlich dem aufschwung
der deutschen wirtschaft
vornehmliche aufgabe in dieser zeit und
sie ist nicht einfach ist die senkung
und stabilisierung der energiepreise sie
ist deswegen nicht einfach weil
deutschland eben noch in einem hohen
maße abhängig ist von fossilen importen
es ist eben eine gas in flächen die wir
im moment erleben sie treiben die preise
an die markt märkte sind so ausgerichtet
dass es immer der höchste preis den der
höchsten die höchste oder den preis
bestimmt und das sind im moment die gas-
oder je schneller wir also aussteigen
aus dem fossilen energien so günstiger
wird unsere wirtschaft mit energie
versorgt werden können dass das nicht
von heute auf morgen passiert dass das
an viele voraussetzungen gebunden ist
und auch mit vielen widerständen zu
rechnen ist ist selbst evident dass muss
ich an dieser stelle nicht aus für
strategisch ist es jedenfalls allemal
richtig und zwar nicht nur um das klima
zu schützen sondern in die residenz der
deutschen wirtschaft zu erhöhen das ist
die strategie die wir gehen müssen
trotzdem besteht natürlich die aufgabe
jetzt darin
besteht die aufgabe natürlich jetzt
darin die energiepreise zu senken sowohl
für die menschen wie auch für die
unternehmen und senken heißt ja den
preisanstieg gehen wir auch in diesem
jahr prognostiziert erleben werden die
preise werden ja jetzt erst teilweise
weitergegeben den preisanstieg zu
dämpfen das ist günstiger wird das kann
man tatsächlich bei diesem marktumfeld
kaum erwarten aber so werden wir die
eeg-umlage so schnell wie es geht
abschaffen wir werden im bereich der
stromproduktion den eigenen strombedarf
bei mieter strom modellen beispielsweise
aber auch für die unternehmen durch neue
die durch für die industrie oder für die
wirtschaft durch neue innovative formen
der strom direkt an strom direkt
beziehungs verträge unterstützen so dass
diejenigen die direkte lieferung mit in
der erneuerbaren energien produzenten
haben dann tatsächlich einen energie
strom preis bekommen der deutlich unter
dem markt legt das sind die
unterstützungsmaßnahmen die wir im
energiebereich direkt machen können es
wird verklärt werden durch eine reihe
von sozialpolitischen maßnahmen die die
kollegen hier demnächst ja sicherlich
vortragen werden beziehungsweise die
schon öffentlich diskutiert werden wir
werden eine reform der netzentgelte
vornehmen wir werden das mag design im
strommarkt und im energiemarkt neu
anpacken müssen und steuerliche senkung
wie sie alle gefordert sind sind
natürlich theoretisch denkbar aber sie
müssen dann zusammen passen mit anderen
politischen forderungen die erhoben
werden beispielsweise einhaltung der
schuldenbremse
insofern ist das eine
wirtschaftspolitische sinnvolle maßnahme
aber eine haushaltspolitisch
konterkarierte maßnahme das im
haushaltsausschuss mal aufzulösen das
wäre eine interessante eine interessante
über
die clowns beschleunigung die klare zur
steinigung muss vor an dem sie muss
schneller werden ich persönlich bin der
meinung dass ersatzneubauten ohne
größere genehmigungsverfahren ermöglicht
werden sollen da wohl schon etwas steht
sollte das gleiche am stand der technik
orientiert nach vorne gebracht werden
können die legal planung das heißt
gemeinschaftliche deutsche europäische
interessen per beschluss hier oder in
anderen parlamenten im landesparlamenten
gegebenenfalls festzulegen halte ich
ebenfalls für eine opportune möglichkeit
damit wir das ob der debatte dann
irgendwann parlamentarisch entscheiden
können natürlich gibt es dann eine menge
von planungsverfahren und der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien ist wie es im
koalitionsvertrag
festgeschrieben ist von öffentlichem
interesse ich würde sogar sagen vom
herausragenden im öffentlichen interesse
so dass die abwägungsprozess zwischen
den verschiedenen schutzgüter bis wir
die leistungsfähigkeit der erneuerbaren
energien aus den genannten gehen dass
alliance gründen erreicht haben
vorrangig zu behandeln ist im bereich
der digitalisierung muss das markt wird
neu geordnet werden ein geschäftsfeld
für viele unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer viele start up unternehmen
die eine enorme dynamik entwickelt haben
und auch entwickeln können da dieses
feld immer international ist arbeiten
wir stark und bringen mit europäischen
kommission den digital market act und
den social service act jetzt endlich zum
abschluss zu bringen um dann ein
organisiertes marktfeld zu haben indem
europa seine kreativität seine digitale
kreativität auslösen und nach vorne
bringen kann es bleibt die arbeit an den
fachkräften sprach schon an den sprach
schon darüber dass die das ist diesen
zusatz dieses kapitel in dem in dem
jahreswirtschaftsbericht gibt eine der
erschreckten zahlen die ich je gelesen
habe ist dass die quote der
schulabgänger ohne abschluss noch immer
bei zehn prozent liegt wir entlassen
zehn prozent der jungen leute aus der
schule ohne dass sie beruflich
qualifiziert sind das kann so nicht
bleiben wenn wir davon reden ist dass
die erste aufgabe die wir
an gegenmitteln aber natürlich werden
wir auch zu organisieren müssen über ein
punktesystem über anwerbung in allen
bereichen hoch qualifizierte menschen
geben dienstleistungsbereich arbeiten
sehr geehrte damen und herren wenn man
sich anschaut wo wir stehen und wie
volatil das umfeld ist so kann man
leicht sagen man müsse das für große
schwierigkeiten wie sollen wir da bloß
durchkommen nur wenn man sich anschaut
wo wir stehen und wie man die
verschiedenen indikatoren zusammen nimmt
dann kann man die geschichte auch anders
erzählen und das ist das was der
jahreswirtschaftsbericht unter dem
strich sagt es ist ein bericht der
vorsichtigen hoffnung es ist möglich
wirkt wachstum von
treibhausgasemissionen zu entkoppeln und
wir sehen ist in den grafiken es ist
möglich den gesamt die gesamt
rohstoffproduktivität zu erhöhen sie
steigt wir haben also ein höheres
wachstum und verbrauchen weniger
rohstoffe es ist möglich den
flächenverbrauch zu reduzieren
wir sehen es an den zahn es ist möglich
die luft von schadstoffen frei zu halten
obwohl die wirtschaft weiter wächst es
ist möglich die einkommensungleichheit
zu verringern bei einer erwachsenen
wirtschaft es ist möglich und wir sehen
ist dass mehr frauen in
führungspositionen sind und der gender
pay gap sich langsam schließt das ist
alles nicht schnell genug im
klimabereich im sozialen bereich wir
haben eine große aufgabe vor uns aber
dass sie möglichst ist das beweist
dieser bericht das beweist die
vergangenheit liegen wir also entlang
diesen bericht die hände nicht in den
schoß sondern packen wir an sehen wir zu
dass wir die dynamik entfalten die
produktivität den wohlstand in diesem
land zu erhöhen und gleichzeitig den
zusammenhalt in diesem land den schutz
der umwelt und den schutz des klimas
nach vorne zu bringen wir können
die linke
die dinge können besser werden wenn sie
besser gemacht werden eine residente
wirtschaft ein jahrzehnt der
zukunftsinvestitionen ein ausgewogenes
wachstumsmodell das sind die stichworte
für einen bericht der vorsichtigen
hoffnung vielen dank
die regierungserklärung von robert
habeck des bundesministers für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz zum
jahreswirtschaftsbericht
20 22 eine beschreibung der aktuellen
lage und der ziele der bundesregierung
und auch des wirtschaftsministers die
eeg-umlage will er so schnell es geht
abschaffen und dann gab es noch ein
klein verweis auf unterschiedliche
vorstellungen innerhalb der koalition
nämlich der verweis darauf dass
steuersenkung im zusammenhang mit der
schuldenbremse zu denken sein erster
redner aus der opposition jens spahn
stellvertretender vorsitzender der
unionsfraktion
herr minister wir haben im dezember eine
klima eröffnungsbilanz vorgenommen wie
man das so macht als neue regierung
diese debatte hier ist eine gute
gelegenheit für eine wirtschaftliche
eröffnungsbilanz und der zwei aspekte
was haben sie vorgefunden habe
übernehmen ein land mit sehr niedriger
arbeitslosigkeit von deutlich unter 6
prozent und das bei einer rekordzahl von
über 46 millionen erwerbstätigen zu
übernehmen ein land auf dem
wachstumspfad ein land das fast ein
jahrzehnt des aufschwungs und der
haushaltsüberschüsse hinter sich hat ein
land mit einer wirtschaft das und das
zeigen die zahlen trotz dieses
weltweiten exogenen schocks der pandemie
sich gut schlägt der erste teil der
eröffnungsbilanz sagt also das erbe das
sie angetreten haben das kann sich sehen
lassen und ist ein erbe nach 16 jahren
unionsgeführte bundesregierung unter
angela merkel und daran werden wir sie
messen er habe in den nächsten jahren
der zweite teil der eröffnungsbilanz
beschreibt die lage am anfang des jahres
ukraine krise fragen von krieg und
frieden
omikron
lieferprobleme inflation hohe
energiepreise drohende zinssteigerung
viele menschen haben bei steigenden
preisen am ende des monats weniger im
portemonnaie und an den börsen rutschen
die kurse
es herrscht eine große wirtschaftliche
unsicherheit in einer solchen lage
braucht das land führung braucht die
wirtschaft sicherheit verlässlichkeit
vertrauen
stattdessen werden zigtausende
häuslebauer und handwerker über nacht
verunsichert und vor den kopf gestoßen
weil sie plötzlich feststellen dass sie
zu wenig geld haben das desaster mit der
bauförderung enthält alle zutaten wie
man es nicht machen sollte kein gesunder
pragmatismus keinen sinn für die
bürgerinnen und bürger und vor allem
keine planungssicherheit wie sie bei der
windkraft immer gebetsmühlenartig
einfordern
im ergebnis richten sie mehrfach schaden
anzulasten von dringend notwendigen
fortschritten bei eigentum und wohnraum
zu lasten des klimaschutzes zu lasten
des vertrauens zur habeck beenden sie
dieses chaos und legen sie endlich einen
plan vor wie sie mit den zigtausenden
anträgen der familien umgehen wollen die
brauchen keine schönen worte die
brauchen entscheidungen und zwar jetzt
und in diesen stunden
und in dieser unsicheren
wirtschaftlichen lage erwartet der
geneigte leser im
jahreswirtschaftsbericht
antworten zu den drängenden fragen also
was ist der plan dieser bundesregierung
was ist ihr plan her habeck bei der
inflation denn ja die inflation hat
kurzfristige gründe pandemie folgen
lieferketten politisch
motiviert bei gas und öl aber
inflation und das zeigt ja auch der
bericht das wird ein länger anhaltendes
phänomen sein energie wird teurer die
löhne werden steigen aufgrund des
fachkräftemangels und die notenbanken
haben kaum spielraum zu handeln wir
brauchen hier mehr taten statt schöner
worte denn am ende sind die dinge für
die bürgerinnen und bürger sehr konkret
in der lohntüte auf der stromabrechnung
auf dem sparbuch
inflation ist zutiefst ungerecht sie
belastet vor allem die hart arbeitende
mitte inflation das ist diebstahl am
kleinen mann und deswegen warten wir
hier mehr als ankündigen wir wollen
konkrete taten sehen wie sie bei der
inflation als bundesregierung sich
positionieren jetzt und nicht in zwei
wochen oder zwei monaten
und was der herr beck ist in dieser
unsicheren zeit ihr plan für ein
stabiles wirtschaftswachstum
denn neben der inflation droht in diesem
jahr zehn stagnierendes wachstum
die alterung der gesellschaft schwächt
die produktivität und die energiewende
die ist zuallererst einmal
milliardenschwere umbau ohne sofortige
wohlstands oder produktivitätsgewinne
wenn es einen ertrag gibt dann erst in
jahren oder jahrzehnten was wir für
unsere älter werdende gesellschaft
allerdings brauchen mehr denn je ist
eine steigerung der produktivität das
haben sie gut beschrieben aber was folgt
daraus es braucht klassische
wachstumspolitik eine reform der
unternehmensteuer bezahlbare
energiepreise
investition in neue technologien freien
handel der wirtschaftsminister außen
wirtschaftsminister was ist eigentlich
mit ca
dann legen sie endlich den deutschen
bundestag zur abstimmung vor handel mit
kanada wenn sie es nicht mehr schaffen
eine mehrheitlich dieser koalition zu
haben für freien handel mit den
liberalen kanada mit wem wollen sie
überhaupt noch handeln auch dafür wollen
wir eine antwort haben dazu wollen wir
was von ihnen hört und wenn sie es nicht
vorlägen hier zur abstimmung wenn wir es
vorlegen notfalls jede woche muss
endlich ratifiziert werden hier im
deutschen bundestag
sie wollen planungsverfahren verbessern
vor allem für den energie ausbauen warum
soll davon nicht die gesamte wirtschaft
profitieren warum sollen für die
montagehallen nicht die gleichen
schnelleren verfahren gelten wie für die
windkraftanlagen und sie haben wieder
einmal mehr auch über die frage von
naturschutz artenschutz klimaschutz
gesprochen ja das ist richtig aber man
fragt sich ob frau lemke ob das
umweltministerium von dem weiß was sie
da sagen sie haben es jetzt zum dritten
mal hier angekündigt wir wollen auch
hier endlich konkrete vorschläge sehen
genug der worte taten braucht es
vorschläge bei den planungsverfahren wie
du auch dort einen unterschied machen
zu alldem anschuldigung erlauben sie
eine zwischenfrage aus der fraktion die
linke ich halte nichts davon wenn nach
einer regierungsbefragung die opposition
sich selbst befragt nein zu all dem
zu alldem findet sich in dem
wirtschaftsbericht wenig es ist vor
allem ein bericht mit hohem klima anteil
was ist ihr plan herr minister für eine
soziale energiepolitik sie wollen eine
sozial ökologische marktwirtschaft ich
gebe den eindruck es geht ihm vor allem
um die ökologische marktwirtschaft das
sozial droht bei ihnen runter zu kippen
das sagen ja auch schon den
sozialdemokraten in öffentlichen
diskussionen
verbrennungsmotoren gegen elektroautos
gas und öl ofen gegen wärmepumpen zu
tauschen all das wird die menschen viel
geld kosten und dass wir das land viel
geld kosten deswegen ist ihre
klimapolitik doch in wahrheit mehr als
alles andere auf wirtschaftswachstum
angewiesen denn nur eine wachsende
volkswirtschaft wird die ressourcen
bereitstellen können die es braucht um
diese energiewende
ohne soziale und worten zu gestalten und
deswegen können sie uns nicht weismachen
dass wachstum per se nicht mehr so
wichtig wäre sie wollen indikatoren
neben dem bruttoinlandsprodukt
entwickeln denn wirtschaftliches
wachstum das wäre ja nicht alles das mag
stimmen aber
ohne wachstum ist alles andere auch
nicht viel wenn die wirtschaft schrumpft
geht es millionen menschen in
deutschland schlechter ohne wachstum
mehr ungleichheit keine höheren renten
keine gute bildung für alle keine
eigenen vier wände im übrigen sollte der
staat niemals besseres leben oder glück
definieren wollen ich finde wenn man das
mal zu ende denkt der staat definiert
was glück ist was besseres leben ist
dann endet das schnell in der unfreiheit
es gibt in deutschland gott sei dank ja
ja ja es gibt in deutschland gott sei
dank über 80 millionen verschiedene
vorstellungen von glück und vom besseren
leben was der staat tun sollte dem
einzelnen wirtschaftlichen wohlstand
faire chancen und soziale sicherheit
geben damit der seines glückes schmied
sein kann und dafür braucht es
wirtschaftliches wachstum gerade in den
nächsten jahren
stecken sie also weniger aufmerksamkeit
denn immer neue kapitel mit immer neuen
indikatoren und stecken sie mehr kraft
und energie in eine politik des
wachstums und des wohlstandes frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen kollegen
dieser tage begehen wir den 125
geburtstag ludwig erhard der lassen sie
mich grundsätzlich schließen
im jahreswirtschaftsbericht
jahreswirtschaftsbericht wirkt wie ein
nachruf auf die soziale marktwirtschaft
daher ist das gegenteil richtig die
soziale marktwirtschaft ist das
zeitgemäße konzept um ökologie und
marktwirtschaft zu verbinden prinzipien
die haftung und offene märkte führen zum
länder und sektorübergreifenden
emissionshandel zu einem umfassenden
verständnis von nachhaltigkeit und zum
offenen freihandel mit dem wir die
deutsche klimatechnik und hier auch in
die welt exportieren können staatliche
transformation ersetzt nicht die kraft
des wettbewerbs neue wohlfahrts
integratoren ersetzen keine neue
wertschöpfung
absichtserklärungen ersetzen keine
freiheit das abkommen statt immer neuer
adjektive braucht die soziale
marktwirtschaft eine bundesregierung die
sich an diesen bewährten prinzipien
orientiert
sie
kommen sie bitte zum schluss haben am
ende gesagt es ging darum geschichten zu
erzählen herr minister weniger poesie
mehr machen das wäre eine gute
eröffnungsbilanz
jens spahn stellvertretender
vorsitzender der unions-fraktion mit zur
regierungserklärung von
bundeswirtschaftsminister habe kehrt
unter anderem angesprochen die förderung
des energieeffizienten sanieren und
bauen stellt die ist ja gestoppt worden
von der kreditanstalt für wiederaufbau
weil es deutlich mehr anträge als
fördermittel gegeben hat das programm
wurde früher gestoppt als geplant
intervention der abgeordnete klaus ernst
von der fraktion die linke klaus ernst
mit einer kurzintervention
herzlichen dank für präsidentin dass sie
die intervention zu lassen herr sparen
jetzt hab ich schon wieder den reflex
dass ich am liebsten die regierung
verteidigen würde bei ihrer
bei dem
nur zwei bemerkten zwei bemerkungen dazu
das erste ist sie haben zeta
angesprochen und sie wollen dass diese
regierung die jetzt ganz schnell
ratifiziert bisher hatte die union im
ausschuss für wirtschaft und energie
jedenfalls in der letzten legislatur die
ist ja noch nicht ganz so lange her
immer die position dass sie das erst
dann machen will wenn das
bundesverfassungsgericht urteilt zu
dieser frage erkranken ist jetzt sind
sie in der opposition unseres gegenteil
wie vorher immer so ganz so glaubwürdig
kommt es nichts kommt es nicht über
ersparen
also wenn sie da was substanzielles
wollen müssen sie müssen sie mehr
anbieten als poesie die sie gerade
einseitig vor die und bewaffnet haben
also die sage ich ja schon eher an ein
gedicht vortragen erinnern und die
allgemeinplätze die sie die cd der
verdrehten hab ich sage auch hier
sie haben auf die freie kräfte des
marktes wir haben in der letzten
legislatur oft darüber gesprochen hier
in diesem saal das genau die freien
kräfte des marktes nicht ausreichen um
die zukunft wirklich zu bewältigen
deshalb hat auch ihr e mail gmail
wirtschaftsminister ein
industriepolitisches programm vorgelegt
vielleicht erinnern sie sich mal dran
dass die regierung damals der es hier
angehört haben schon weiter war als
jetzt die opposition
ersparen möchten sie antworten
[Applaus]
gerne kurz lieber ernst das ist so beim
regieren das stimmt bei c a haben wir
bis jetzt ein kompromiss in der
koalition einnehmen müssen aber eines
war immer klar die grundsätzliche
position der union dazu wir sind für
freien handel und wir sind für mehr
handelsabkommen aus verschiedenen
gründen
aus ganz verschiedenen gründen wir haben
zum beispiel in dieser pandemie gesehen
einmal mehr schmerzhaft wie sehr wir
abhängig sind von china wer weniger
abhängig werden will von diesem ein
landwirtschaftlich braucht mehr
handelsabkommen mit anderen regionen der
welt und ja deswegen ich meine wir
werden ja sehen wie die fdp sich
verhalten wird bei ca die uns ja
mehrfach hier vorgeschlagen hat zeitnah
zu ratifizieren
deswegen werden wir bei merkur bei japan
bei allen handelsverträgen sie hier
immer wieder stellen wenn dieses land
das mehr als jedes andere land auf
export angewiesen ist gut auch durch die
nächsten jahre kommen will geld haben
will um die klimawende zu finanzieren
und sozial abzufedern dann brauchen wir
mehr handel mit anderen regionen auf der
welt und ich sage noch einmal und das
gilt auch an die linkspartei wenn sie
nicht mal mit dem liberalen diversen
kanada bereit sind hier ein
handelsabkommen zu ratifizieren mit
welchem land wollen sie dann überhaupt
noch denn nur handel innerhalb der
bundesrepublik löst das problem
jedenfalls nicht und deswegen werden wir
sie jetzt zur abstimmung stellen
die antwort von jetzt sparen auf die
kurzintervention von klaus ernst aus der
linksfraktion und was ich vorher noch
anfügen wollte 20.000 anträge auf
förderung von energieeffizientem
sanieren und bauen liegen derzeit auf
eis mit kommen möglicherweise nicht zum
zuge das rückgängig zu machen fordert
die unionsfraktion in einem
entschließungsantrag jetzt verena hubert
für die spd fraktion
jedes unternehmen muss gewisse
kennzahlen umsatz ebit-marge
akquisitionskosten vielleicht nochmal
runtergebrochen auf verschiedene
geschäftsbereiche ist aber wichtig die
richtigen zahlen zu identifizieren und
dann daran auch zu steuern und
auszurichten nicht auf das
offensichtliche zu schauen sondern auf
das wesentliche wonach gucken wir denn
eigentlich in unserer wirtschaft ja das
bruttoinlandsprodukt ist ein konzept
angefangen mit der sozialen
marktwirtschaft im aufstieg aber wir
haben immer auf das reine mehr an
einkommen geschaut und auch das
versprechen dass es die eigenen kinder
einmal besser haben werden die zeiten
sind natürlich jetzt schon auch ein
bisschen angespannt da und wir haben
auch themen des mangels die wir uns
anschauen müssen ich mach das mal an
drei beispielen fest ein mangel an
ressourcen
das ist endlich ob bei seltenen erden
halbleitern aber auch fossile
brennstoffe deswegen brauchen wir
alternativen wir haben ein mangel an
fachkräften die köpfe in unserem land
das ist doch die ressource der zukunft
wir haben die baby gemacht
die langsame in rente gehen und wir
haben wie der minister angesprochen habe
zehn prozent aller menschen die die
schule verlassen die keinen abschluss
haben das geht nicht und wir haben ein
mangel an zeit
wenn wir sind die letzte generation die
jetzt bei den erneuerbaren nach vorne
kommen muss und da schließt sich
ökologie und ökonomie gar nicht aus und
das zeigt doch der
jahreswirtschaftsbericht wir stehen da
ja mit einer wirtschaftsleistung die
dieses jahr voraussichtlich um 3,6
prozent steigt und einer soliden basis
bei der arbeitslosenquote
und wenn wir jetzt auf den
jahreswirtschaftsbericht schauen dann
steht auch genau in dem titel
sozial ökologische marktwirtschaft und
dieses dreieck das muss uns doch in der
zukunft gelingen
und schwendemann freund von plakativen
beispielen warum es eben nicht reicht
nur auf das bild zu schauen ich wurde
einer mietwohnung angenommen ich habe
jetzt ein wasserrohrbruch und unter mir
die mietwohnungen die läuft freuen mit
wasser die wand muss ausgetauscht werden
die küchengeräte sind kaputt die familie
muss zwei wochen ins hotel damit alles
wieder gerichtet werden kann
ökonomisch bedeutet dass wir generieren
umsatz verkaufen neue geräte der
handwerker wird bestellt aber entsteht
dadurch irgendwie eine art des
nachhaltigen wohlstandes nein denn wir
tauschen uns aus und deswegen ist es so
wichtig
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir
jetzt ein sonderkapitel haben und uns
nicht nur auf die geldflüsse fokussieren
sondern auch auf andere kennzahlen
naja so jetzt haben wir da trat seien
drin wie die gerechtigkeit die
gerechtigkeit zwischen löhnen zwischen
männern und frauen das ist einfach
ungerecht dass frauen immer noch weniger
in diesem land verdient und es ist
unsere aufgabe die playtech endlich mal
zu weisen wir gucken uns den
flächenverbrauch an aber auch die
forschungsintensität von waren
ist doch nicht egal ob wir in zukunft
braunkohle verkaufen sondern wir müssen
doch hinkommen zu solarpanels und all
diese zahlen die werden jetzt einmal
aufbereitet und bieten uns eine
grundlage des steuers unserer
marktwirtschaft wie eben auch auf die
sozialen und die nachhaltige aspekte
fokussiert und sich anschaut
und deswegen ist das was wir jetzt
vorgestellt haben auch ein philosophie
wandel wie blicken wir auf unsere
wirtschaft und welche zahlen nehmen wir
da mit rein wir wollen nicht nur das
öffentliche offensichtliche sehen
sondern auch das wesentliche und ich bin
da sehr optimistisch dass wir mit dem
richtigen kennzahlen unsere zukunft
anpacken und das werden wir beschlossen
tun als bundesregierung und eben diesen
trägt an hinbekommen und darauf freue
ich mich bereits sehr
wir reden der who die spd-fraktion da
ist sich der vertretende vorsitzende mit
ihrem beitrag zur aussprache zum
jahreswirtschaftsbericht den der
bundeswirtschaftsminister habe hier
vorgestellt hat für die afg fraktion
geht jetzt ans pult in rico comic
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer seiner
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin lieber
minister habeck sehr geehrte frau hubert
vielleicht passen sie jetzt mal auf sie
haben wir viel von mangel gesprochen ich
habe den eindruck dass mangelt hier an
den wirtschaftspolitischen sachverstand
in dieser bundesregierung also nach
ihren ausführungen glaube ich erhärtet
sich dass und der weg ich weiß nicht wo
sie ihren wirtschaftspolitischen
sachverstand her haben schauen sie ich
bin wirtschaftsanwalt komme aus der
freien wirtschaft und ich kann ihnen
sagen was sie hier heute
erzählt haben das klingt schon alles
gelinde gesagt sehr abenteuerlich
ihre regierungserklärung und der
jahreswirtschaftsbericht ist endgültig
ein abgesang auf freiheit soziale
marktwirtschaft und breiten wohlstand
für die menschen hier in deutschland
sie sprachen beide die indikatoren die
ja sehr breit ausgeführt sind im
jahreswirtschaftsbericht an dieses
indikatoren würden war soll wohl
offensichtlich dass bisher doch recht
vernünftige
bruttoinlandsprodukt als
bewertungsgrundlage als gradmesser für
unsere wirtschaftliche entwicklung
herangezogen werden ich kann nur sagen
ich denke dass dieses indikatoren würden
genau das alles verschleiern soll was
ich vorher sagte in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag steht und ich zitiere
mit erlaubnis der präsidentin wir
stellen die weichen auf eine sozial
ökologische marktwirtschaft und leiten
ein jahrzehnt der zukunftsinvestitionen
ein zitat ende richtiger hätte es heißen
müssen bestellen die weichen auf eine
unsoziale öko religiöse planwirtschaft
und leiten ein jahrzehnt der volks
verarmung 1
sie zwingen die wirtschaft in einen in
einen zugeschnitten grünen
ordnungsrahmen mit gigantischen
fehlallokationen von geld und
wirtschaftsgütern sie schaffen eine
links-grüne käseglocke der fernab
jeglicher realität die menschen herbeck
werden unter dieser käseglocke ersticken
und zwar nicht allzu viel co2
ersticken wird auch jedes kleine
pflänzchen von wirtschaftswachstum
sie befeuern eine galoppierende
inflation und vernichten damit die
effizienz förderung von neubauten haben
sie einfach mal so eingedampft viele
häuslebauer stehen vor dem nichts ihr
groß versprochenes klima geld
verschwindet klammheimlich in der
schublade die abschaffung der ökostrom
anlage gleicht nicht ansatzweise das aus
was sie den menschen mit der erhöhung
der co2 steuer aus der tasche ziehen
durch das von ihnen
mitgetragene corona chaos verlieren
kleine mittelständische unternehmen
allein im jahr 2020 in deutschland
nahezu 300 milliarden euro dass es fast
ein bundeshaushalt also vor ihren
steuert orgien ihr geplantes bürokratie
entlastungsgesetz beschleunigt allein
willkür genehmigungen von natur
zerstören den windrädern und solarparks
weiter nichts gute und soziale
wirtschaftspolitik zeigt dagegen unser
antrag von fd mit ihrer zustimmung
könnten hier enorme wachstumspotenziale
geschaffen werden mit bessere
aufbereitung öffentlicher daten und
deren nutzung für private innovationen
und geschäftsmodelle
meine damen und herren die von der
bundesregierung propagierte
klimagerechtigkeit schließt jedoch jede
soziale gerechtigkeit aus es profitieren
allein superreiche banker
finanzinvestoren konzernchefs denn die
können sich ihr gutes gewissen erkaufen
zurückgelassen werden arbeiter
angestellte krankenschwestern handwerker
mittelständische unternehmer diejenigen
die von früh
bis spät arbeiten und ihren ganzen
quatsch finanzieren und nicht zuletzt
die rentner und kinder
und für die meine damen und herren für
die machen wir als fdp politik vielen
dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion der
abgeordnete reinhard houben
[Applaus]
ja frau präsidentin
meine damen und herren lieber jens spahn
also aus persönlicher erfahrung kann ich
nur eins sagen es ist einfacher erst
vier jahre in opposition zu sein und
dann in die regierung zu kommen
umgekehrt scheint irgendwie schwieriger
zu sein
aber es war um das thema sofort
abzulösen
[Applaus]
natürlich hat die fdp eine explizite
position zu 10 das habe ich häufig genug
vorgetragen sie haben ungefähr meine
worte übernommen vielen dank dafür aber
sie haben sehr deutlich gesagt dass man
eben auch in der opposition eine klarere
position einnehmen muss und in einer
ampel offensichtlich kompromisse wir
haben im koalitionsvertrag eine
formulierung gefunden die nicht
schlechter ist als die der letzten
koalition deswegen brauchen sie uns an
der stelle nicht angreifen und ich
empfehle
ich empfehle den besuch des
wirtschaftsausschusses denn der
wirtschaftsminister habe ich war in der
letzten sitzung anwesend und hat über
seine brüsseler gespräche berichtet und
da hat er vielleicht nicht von der
hierarchie so weit oben aber durchaus
das thema handelsverträge angesprochen
dass er dort in brüssel in gesprächen
ist also gehen sie davon aus dass wir in
dieser ampel durchaus dieses thema
kontrovers debattieren aber zu positiven
ergebnissen kommen
ein weiterer vorwurf erstaunt das kann
ich ihnen jetzt nicht ersparen ist
folgendes diese regierung ist
immer die weihnachtstage abzieht
vielleicht acht bis zehn wochen im amt
vielleicht wäre ihre rede gut gewesen in
einem jahr aber diese regierung jetzt
schon solche vorwürfe zu machen finde
ich schwierig und wie heißt es so schön
jeder hammer den mann wirft kommt
irgendwann zurück ich hätte mir
gewünscht wenn das politikmanagement des
gesundheitsministers sparen uns nicht
diese schrecklichkeiten in der masten
frage gebracht hätte jeder einkäufer von
lidl oder edeka hätte das problem
preiswerter ohne subventionen vernünftig
gelöst
und
frauke da wird ja gleich noch sprechen
vogel ja gleich noch sprechen sie hat ja
eine wunderbare pressemitteilung heraus
gebracht wo sie sagt sei ein wachstums
kritischer abgesang der sozialen
marktwirtschaft und es brauche für eine
prosperierende
wirtschaftspolitik mehr als ein
ökologisches glücksindex und neue
wohlstands kriterien
frau klöckner
meine damen und herren von der
unionsfraktion
ja es sind neue aspekte in diesem
wirtschaftsbericht aufgenommen worden
und ich verstehe auch die empörung in
der debatte nicht richtig es ist doch
seinerzeit einer konkret kommission auch
wenn ihre unterstützung eingerichtet
worden wo man über die frage
der erweiterung der themen in einem
wirtschaftsgericht diskutierter wo ihre
leute auch nicht gemacht leider ist das
ergebnis der enquete-kommission da
sollten wir vielleicht mal was ändern in
den schubladen versunken und keiner hat
sich damit beschäftigt klar ist meine
damen und herren es gibt interessante
aspekte aber die entscheidende botschaft
des wirtschafts berichtes ist und bleibt
wo stehen wir beim vip und wie versöhnen
wir die frage des wohlstandes und des
wirtschaftlichen erfolges mit den fragen
zum beispiel auch ökologische oder
soziale fragen aber das bibb ist am ende
die größe die uns auch im
internationalen vergleich zeigt wo wir
stehen und wir müssen alle daran
arbeiten auch in dieser neuen regierung
dass es wieder nach bewohner in
deutschland wirtschaftlich aufrecht
gehen vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fraktion die
linke ist christian laie den ich sehr
herzlich zu seiner ersten rede hier im
deutschen bundestag beschließen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren ich möchte meine erste
rede gerne mit etwas positivem beginn es
ist aus unserer sicht ein fortschritt
dass erstmalig im
jahreswirtschaftsbericht die soziale
ungleichheit skizziert wird allerdings
und das ist mein thema das muss auch
folgen haben für die politik der
regierung
worum geht es wenn sie in gelsenkirchen
auf einem spielplatz drei kinder sehen
dann wächst statistisch eines davon in
armut auf und gleichzeitig besitzen
45 familien in diesem land so viel
vermögen wie die hälfte der bevölkerung
und diese ungerechten verhältnisse sind
auch das ergebnis der politik in diesem
hohen hause spd und grüne und fdp und
union kam in wechselnden
regierungskonstellationen diese
verhältnisse in gesetze gegossen und
wenn wir in diesen tagen viel über die
spaltung der gesellschaft sprechen dann
dürfen wir nicht vergessen die
gesellschaft wurde durch eine sozial
ungerechte politik bereits vor der
pandemie gespalten meine damen und
herren
und deswegen darf seine
wirtschaftspolitik sich nicht nur fragen
warum sind die märkte nervös sie muss
sich vor allen dingen fragen warum sind
die menschen nervös und die menschen
sind nervös angesichts der notwendigen
transformation angesichts von preisen
die die decke gehen 18 prozent mehr für
energie 6 prozent mehr für lebensmittel
41 prozent mehr für heizöl und wenn dann
der grüne landwirtschaftsminister auch
noch höhere lebensmittelpreise
einfordert ohne zu erklären wie menschen
mit niedrigem einkommen das stimmt
sollen dann kommt bei vielen nur an wenn
sie kein geld für brot haben dann sollen
sie doch bio dinkel brötchen kaufen und
deswegen sage ich ihnen ökologischen
nachhaltigkeit muss sozial nachhaltig
sein sonst ist sie nicht politisch
nachhaltig meine damen und herren
aber nicht nur die einkommen halten mit
den ausgaben nicht mit auch die kosten
für die transformation sind enorm laut
einer studie im auftrag der kfw betragen
sie rund 100 milliarden euro pro jahr
und auch die grünen haben kürzlich noch
mit 50 milliarden euro pro jahr
mindestens gerechnet und die ironie ist
doch nicht nur die menschen können sich
grüne wirtschaftspolitik nicht leisten
nein auch der grüne wirtschaftsminister
kann sich grüne wirtschaftspolitik nicht
leisten wenn man sich das rum beamten um
den nachtragshaushalt gestern an sieht
meine damen und herren und deswegen
sagen wir lassen sie die finger von der
schwarzen null sie gefährdet die grünen
012 besteuern sie große vermögen endlich
gerecht und warum allein der besitzer
von lille ist nur in der krise um 25
milliarden euro reicher geworden zum
vergleich eine kassiererin müsste für
diese summe rund 847 1000 jahre arbeiten
sie hätte anfangen müssen zu arbeiten
bevor es den modernen menschen überhaupt
gar wie zum teufel wollen sie den
menschen da draußen diese
ungerechtigkeit eigentlich noch erklären
und steuern sie diese großen panne
endlich die rechts- und
warum das möchte ich an einem beispiel
aus meinem wahlkreis erläutern in
duisburg wackelt die stahlindustrie
17.000 kern arbeitsplätze sind gefährdet
zehntausende weitere arbeitsplätze in
einer region hier sowieso schon von
armut betroffen ist und hier muss geld
fließen viel geld um die produktion auf
co2 freien stahl umzustellen und
deswegen sagen wir
erstens die regierung muss endlich
handeln geredet wurde zu lange die
kolleginnen und kollegen vor ort warten
auf entscheidung zweites öffentliches
geld muss fließen aber wenn öffentliches
geld fließt dann muss das auch zu
öffentlichem eigentum führen das ist
gerecht dass es demokratisch und das ist
die übung auch nachhaltig dieses waren
nicht zuletzt die kapitalistischen
eigentumsverhältnisse die in die
klimakrise geführt haben meine damen und
herren deswegen letzter satz
transformationen wirtschaftspolitik muss
aus der perspektive der menschen mit
niedrigem einkommen gedacht werden damit
sie nachhaltig sein kann vielen dank
nächster redner für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen detail ja nicht schön
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin franz
müntefering ein kluger analytiker hat
einmal gesagt opposition
ist mist
ich würde ihm da widersprechen
wir haben ja die erfahrung ich zumindest
persönlich aus acht jahren opposition
man kann diese zeit nutzen um kluge
konzepte zu entwickeln sich an der
regierung auch abzuarbeiten aber ich
würde sagen in richtung die union auch
gefragt ich würde ihnen nicht empfehlen
dort zu kritisieren wo sie auch ihre
eigenen grundwerte in frage stellen und
dieses beispiel mit dem energie haus
standard 55 diesen schlecht konzipierten
programm das sie verlängert haben das
dazu geführt hätte dass wir jetzt
milliarden steuermittel für einen
standard ausgegeben hätten den wir
sowieso als standard kriegen würden und
da auch dank an den finanzminister an
den wirtschaftsminister dass sie dort
eingeschritten sind da jetzt auch
einzuschreiten und zusagen
marktwirtschaft heißt dass wir das geld
so investieren dass das meiste und nicht
das wenigste co2 rauskommt das ist doch
ein richtiger schritt und den haben wir
vollzogen und das war richtig sucht
und das wird übrigens auch weiter so
sein dass wir bei den programmen die
auch die industrie fordert nicht alle
nachgeben werden was das größte und
schnellste und weiteste ist sondern
immer im augenblick uns angucken werden
was ist effizient und was wird der markt
richten und nicht dass das
wirtschaftsministerium die verlängerte
werkbank der industrie und lobbyverbände
ist das möchte ich auch mal eindeutig
sagt herr janitschek erlauben sie eine
frage von frau sitte aus der fraktion
die linke
danke dieter janácek dass sie das zu
lassen ich habe vorhin gelernt dass man
obwohl mir das noch nie aufgefallen dass
während einer regierungserklärung eines
ministers oder eine ministerin keine
anfrage stellen soll oder darf habe ich
nicht gefunden in der geschäftsordnung
ist egal im kern ging es mir um die
aufstellung des zentralen
innovationsprogramms mittelstand sie
haben jetzt gerade programme angerissen
die auch gefordert werden von der
wirtschaft und wir beide wissen ja
relativ gut dass das zentrale
innovationsprogramm mittelstand ein sehr
nachgefragtes programm ist dass es
insbesondere unternehmen forschende
mittelständler unterstützt mit einem
anteil von unter 50 beschäftigten das
aber der sozial ökologische umbau die
transformation nicht möglich ist ohne
die innovativen unternehmen gerade in
diesem mittelständischen bereich und bin
ist es so dass es unter union schon
jahrelang dieses zentrale
innovationsprogramm bei 550 millionen
etwa im jahr lag gab eine kleine
erhöhung um 30 millionen vor 34 jahren
aber es ist immer noch extrem
nachgefragt und jetzt haben wir es
erhöht worden während der korona
pandemie durch das zukunftspaket auf 620
jetzt ist aber im nachtrag es
nachtragshaushalt beziehungsweise im
haushaltsentwurf für 22 wieder die 550
millionen drin wir wissen aber dass seit
oktober keine neuen anträge gestellt
werden können dass es einen antragsstau
gibt und deshalb wollte ich eigentlich
den minister aber sie sprechen ja
sozusagen für die regierungstragende
fraktion
ihre orientierung mit blick auf das
zentrale innovationsprogramm mittelstand
erfragen was welche chancen geben sie
eine erweiterung dieses budgets für die
nächsten jahre um eben gerade diese
innovativen potenziale auch für
zielstellung wie sie sie richtigerweise
folgen zu mobilisieren
vielen dank für diese gute frage und das
ist auch gerade der stil von opposition
den ich gerade auch von als ein den wir
auch selbst gepflegt haben als wir
zusammen gearbeitet haben in opposition
nämlich zielgerichtet zu schauen nach
den programmen nachzufragen groß
erweiterungsbedarf ich bin allerdings
das möchte ich schon hinzufügen bei
aller freundschaft zum minister nicht
vertreter der regierung sondern der
regierungsfraktionen und insofern werden
wir uns alle programme auch insofern auf
effizienz und zielgerichtetheit
anschauen die korona pandemie war eine
begründung für die erhöhung der mittel
wir hoffen ja sehr dass wir jetzt eine
endemische phase kommen wo auch
wirtschaftsaufschwung wieder in einer an
art und weise möglich ist aber ich kann
ihnen zusagen dass wir das auf jeden
fall in ihrem sinne noch mal anschauen
werden zum jetzigen zeitpunkt kann ich
nicht mehr sagen als wir das uns ganz
genau angucken werden dankeschön
sehr verehrte damen und herren wir
stehen wirtschaftspolitisch zweifellos
vor großen herausforderungen noch immer
belastet die pandemie den einzelhandel
tourismus gastronomie kultur wirtschaft
noch immer brauchen die betroffenen
betriebe unterstützung und sie bekommen
sie auch ich hoffe allerdings sehr und
wir alle hoffen dass das wir in eine
phase kommen wo wir auch von den
maßnahmen runter kommen und dann auch
von den hilfen runterkommen dieser
zeitpunkt ist jetzt noch nicht aber das
ist etwas was wir brauchen hoffentlich
nahe zukunft
die lieferketten sind ein problem gerade
auch bei den halbleitern eine gewisse
entspannung scheint sich abzuzeichnen
aber auch erst im zweiten halbjahr wenn
man der industrie glauben darf das heißt
wir werden weiter ein ruppiges jahr
haben ein jahr mit investitions
unsicherheiten deswegen ist es umso
wichtiger dass diese regierung beim
thema investitionsbereitschaft
fachkräften bei der frage auch wie wir
innovationen vorantreiben auch mit neuen
ansätzen einen kraftvollen aufschlag
macht und das tun wir heute mit diesem
jahreswirtschaftsbericht mit dieser
neuen wirtschaftspolitik die sagt
innovation klimaschutz fachkräfte
einwanderung das gehört zusammen das
wollen wir voranbringen
denn dieses jahrzehnt der zwanziger
jahre soll das jahrzehnte der großen
zukunftsinvestitionen werden und
deswegen kann ich es überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen wenn die union sich
ausgerechnet gegen das projekt der
großen zukunftsinvestitionen wendet
damit werden sie sich herr merz auch
keine freunde in der deutschen industrie
in der deutschen wirtschaft machen die
industrie fordert investitionen sie
fordert modernisierung sie fordert
entschlossenheit sie vor der planungs
beschleunigung und da haben wir eine
gemeinsamkeit zwischen wirtschaft und
regierung dass wir das gemeinsam
voranbringen
und gerade beim thema fachkräftemangel
da kommen wir und eine kritische
diskussion
es ist ja auch ausdruck ihrer politik
der vergangenen man könnte schon sagen
jahrzehnte dass sie es geleugnet haben
dass deutschland ein einwanderungsland
sei dass sie den spurwechsel nicht
ermöglicht haben dass sie nicht gesehen
haben die vielen potenziale auch
übrigens von frauen in technischen
berufen in der wirtschaft in
führungspositionen das wollen wir und
müssen wir jetzt nachholen
und wenn uns das nicht gelingt und es
nicht gelingt auf der fachkräfte seite
die potenziale zu schöpfen dann werden
wir auch die potenziale für die
nachholende modernisierung nicht
schöpfen können also wir müssen das
zusammendenken zusammenbringen da ist
vieles das wir uns vorgenommen haben und
ich finde es nicht schlecht dass wir
eine ambitionierte regierung sind will
ich hinzufügen ich hatte vor kurzem mal
formuliert und gesagt wenn wir die ziele
beim ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
schaffen wäre das ja fast schon
sensationell von hinten her gedacht ist
das ein angebot was wir jetzt machen zu
sagen wir gehen einen entschlossenen weg
wir gehen ladungs beschleunigung mit
klaren leitplanken mit der verbindung
von wirtschaft und klimaschutz weil das
eben beiden seiten nutzt und ich glaube
die diskussionen der vergangenheit wo
wir hier diskussionen und ich kann nicht
leidvoll erinnern um die frage ob jetzt
die elektromobilität oder doch der evs
die bessere zukunftsinvestition sein die
werden ja auf den weltmärkten gar nicht
mehr geführt also ich würde sie auch
bitten ich meinen sie von der afg sie
werden im jahr 2030 noch behaupten dass
braunkohle kraftwerke die
zukunftsinvestitionen sind das ist ein
anderer diskussion strahlen aber mit der
union glaube ich muss die diskussion
darum geführt werden was ist der
effizienteste marktwirtschaftliche haben
um diese wirtschaft sozial und
ökologisch voranzubringen um uns fit zu
machen für das 21 jahrhundert damit wir
wirklich hier die ziele erreichen die
wir uns vorgenommen haben vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die cdu csu
fraktion julia klöckner
[Applaus]
ob als event sind guten morgen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrter
herr beck nur um es klar zu machen damit
sich jetzt nicht irgendeinen
storytelling fest wir klagen nicht gegen
ihren klimafonds
wir klagen
gegen einen verfassungsbruch wir klagen
gegen die verschleierung von schulden
wir klagen dagegen dass diese koalition
unter zuhilfenahme der fdp hier die
schuldenbremse umgehen will und das ist
was komplett anderes als gegen ihrem
thema vorherzusagen nur damit wir das
noch einmal auch klarstellen
und normalerweise sind ja die
antrittsreden ankündigungen das haben
sie es vergangenen mal gemacht aber
eigentlich hat man jetzt erwartet beim
jahreswirtschaftsbericht dass wir über
die ankündigung des koalitionsvertrages
endlich hinauskommen und substanz von
ihnen heute hören das haben wir heute
hier nicht gehört wir haben wieder
irgendwelche ziele erfahren von ihnen
das ist ja auch gut und nett aber dass
es der fdp dabei unwohl wird das haben
wir gemacht haben sie waren ja im
ausschuss noch opposition zu minister
haben einiges kritisiert dass man gut ab
der herum er hat auch schon mal sätze
von hier kommentiert proaktiv
prophylaktisch weil er weiss ich rede
ihres hinterns nach ihm aber man hat
sich eben überhaupt nicht mehr gehört
was die ordnungspolitischen grundsätze
der fdp sind vor der bundestagswahl
haben sie immer auf sita wert gelegt und
im koalitionsvertrag haben sie irgendwie
versucht dran vorbei zu kommen und jetzt
beschimpfen sind diejenigen die eine
klare haltung haben denn ohne handeln
ohne freihandel ohne den kontakt zu den
usa zu
kanada zu denjenigen die uns auch im
austausch am ende zur seite stehen was
die grundlage auch unserer wirtschaft
ist ohne diese klare haltung werden sie
doch hier keine nachvollziehbare klare
wirtschaftspolitik machen können was ist
denn aus der fdp geworden haben sie so
viel grün mit kreide gefressen vergessen
entschuldigung und beide spd die spd
schaut zu wie übrigens bei vielen
anderen themen friedrich merz gestern ja
sehr eindrucksvoll erläutert auch beim
thema ukraine also wir machen dass
dieser
jahreswirtschaftsbericht und wer ihn
liest der titel ist ja mehrfach geändert
worden der titel ist ja erst sie
schleichen ja im titel die soziale
marktwirtschaft und wir haben ja gesehen
dass es einmal
richtung fdp gelingt wird und einmal
gelingt wird richtung grünen auf der
einen seite sagen sie die soziale
marktwirtschaft sei ein überholtes
modell weil sie stark und dynamisch sein
und auf der anderen seite fordern sie
wieder dass wir uns auf die grundsätze
der sozialen marktwirtschaft wieder
rückbesinnen da muss man irgendwann
schon klarheit haben und nicht nur
formelkompromisse zusammen mit der fdp
und aus diesem grund will ich noch
einmal darauf hinweisen was mir hier
wirklich sorge macht in der ganzen frage
denn wenn wir uns anschauen wie der neue
bundeswirtschaftsminister
unseren staat seit gestern er ist
wachstums kritisch nicht dass wir uns
falsch verstehen
auch wir sind der meinung dass unsere
lebens- und arbeitsweise und
nachhaltiger werden muss aber wer eine
so klare absage an das wachstum gibt der
verkennt dass seine transformation zu
einer ökologisch sozialen
marktwirtschaft auch finanzen brauchen
wir müssen uns nicht nur gedanken machen
wie wir leben wollen sondern von was wir
auf leben wollen und darum gehen auch in
diesem
jahreswirtschaftsbericht musste es gehen
an diesem wirtschaftsbericht und ihr
staatssekretär giegold sagte in der
vermeintliche times die rolle des
staates sollte über die schaffung des
ordnungsrahmens hinausgehen wenn wir das
ganze noch einmal konkretisiert sich die
grüne abgeordnete pack im ausschuss in
diesem mittwoch und sie hat es
unmissverständlich dann gesagt zitat
damit damit jetzt mit ihrem
wirtschaftsbericht und ihren
verschiedenen indizes wachstums
bemessungen damit wird eine neue ära der
wohlstand steuerung eingeleitet wie muss
ihnen sagen liebe kolleginnen kollegen
es gibt viele beispiele bemühten
beispiele wo eine solche staatliche
wohlstand steuerung ziemlich stark in
die hose gegangen ist und das zu lasten
der menschen und ich kann ihnen sagen
die soziale marktwirtschaft ist und
bleibt ein erfolgsmodell und
nicht sie im ministerium transformieren
die wirtschaft macher der transformation
sind diese die sie leider viel zu wenig
reden das sind die unternehmer erfinder
und gründer und wer wohlstand zentral
steuern zu können meint der muss etwas
übersinnliches haben wir sind sehr
gespannt auf diesen neuen maßstab für
eine neue bundesregierung und mit ihrer
ersten staatlichen lenken haben sie ja
bekommen karabag mit dem förderstopp
gebäudeeffizienz förderung haben sie die
träume von den eigenen vier wänden von
vielen tausenden familien platzen lassen
und ist auch etwas auch ganz so sagen
naja die sparen nicht genügend co2 ein
jetzt hier bei das ist mal auf das sind
menschen die gucken auf ihren euro die
wollen eigentum schaffen für sich und
ihre familien fürs alter vorsorgen die
haben geplant die haben die anträge
eingereicht wir haben auch diesen staat
vertraut und ihnen fällt über nacht ein
da sie mal kurz die vollbremsung
hinlegen das ist nicht verlässlich das
ist nicht planbar vor allen dingen das
ist nicht nachhaltig
von deshalb
betone ich auch sehr klar wer nicht auch
eine wirtschaft setzt die freiraum hat
für erfindungen für kreativität auch für
ein nachhaltiges wachstum der wird
niemals die sozialen anforderungen die
steigen und auch die transformation zu
einer nachhaltigen sozialen
marktwirtschaft die wird er auch nicht
finanzieren können und deshalb sage ich
noch mal auch zu der gebäudeeffizienz
förderung wir haben heute einen antrag
hier eingebracht um ihnen die chance zu
geben sehr klar auch mit erhobenem haupt
auch das wieder zurückzunehmen was sie
hier als nebelkerze heute vorgelegt
haben deshalb liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir werden als
opposition die 16 jahre lang in der
regierung gewesen ist und da auch für
gesorgt hat dass das kik gewachsen ist
dass wir beides zusammen bekommen haben
co2 minderung und nachhaltiges wachstum
dass das nicht durch planwirtschaftliche
vorgaben
und lenkungen so zerstört wird dass die
privatwirtschaft am ende eine
unterabteilung ihrer transformations-
vorstellungen wird deshalb sage ich sehr
klar die cdu und die csu haben klare
marktwirtschaftliche vorstellungen die
nachhaltig ausgerichtet sind aber wir
können auch rechnen und das sollten sie
auch
[Applaus]
bevor ich den nächsten redner aufrufe
frau klöckner normal ist es nicht üblich
dass man wörtlich ausschusssitzung
zitiert wenn sie nicht öffentlich tagen
man kann sinngemäß ein thema zitieren
aber nicht wörtlich ein zitat übernehmen
aus einer ausschusssitzung nur als
hinweis vielleicht fürs nächste mal an
alle
herzlichen dank ich rufe jetzt auf den
nächsten redner der spd fraktion und das
ist herr sebastian roloff der seine
erste rede heute hält und wie wird er
nie vergessen weil er nämlich heute auch
geburtstag hat herzlichen glückwunsch
verehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen herzlichen dank
für die glückwünsche könnten ja auch
wenig schöneres vorstellen als mit ihnen
heute den jahreswirtschaftsbericht zu
diskutieren weil es tatsächlich viel
positives zu erwähnen gibt aber wenn ich
mir eine sache wünschen darf oder
vielleicht sogar zwei frau klöckner ich
verdanke wenn es ihnen vielleicht mal
gelesen hätten bevor sich werden das
personal auch angehen und wenn ich
gerade schon bayern münchen richten sie
doch vielleicht noch mal ihren
ehemaligen kollegen altmaier ran und
reden sie mit dem über die frage kfw
bauförderung dann wäre glaube ich den
prozess in vielerlei hinsicht gedient
das als frommer geburtstagswünsche ich
bin sehr froh dass der
jahreswirtschaftsbericht nicht nur auf
den sozial-ökologischen umbau eingeht
sondern auch auf die frage wie stehen
wir eigentlich in der krise wie kommen
wir mit der wirtschaft durch die krise
und wir müssen ganz offensichtlich sagen
dass die staatlichen unterstützungen die
staatlichen eingriffe wenn man so will
ganz offensichtlich das schlimmste
verhindert haben die situation ist
schlimm genug aber wer würde zum
beispiel vermeintlich erwarten wenn man
in der thematik nicht drin ist dass die
unternehmensinsolvenzen 2020 auf einem
langen jährigen tief sind sollte man
nicht meinen ganz offensichtlich als das
kurzarbeitergeld genau so eine
erfolgsgeschichte wie die
überbrückungshilfe und das ist genau der
richtige weg gewesen
diese erfolgsgeschichte müssen wir
weiter entwickeln die frage der
transformation kommt mittlerweile in
jeder wirtschaftspolitischen
sonntagsrede vor hat aber für uns alle
tägliche relevanz die unternehmen haben
ihre hausaufgaben gemacht die
gewerkschaften haben ihre hausaufgaben
gemacht arbeitsplätze sind evaluiert
worden qualifikationsbedarf festgestellt
worden strategische
personalbedarfsplanung noch viel mehr
als ohnehin und diesen kraftakt müssen
wir jetzt zusammen schultern das ist ein
kraftakt der unternehmen aber es ist
auch die chance und die notwendigkeit da
dass der staat es unterstützt bei
förderungen bei
qualifizierungsgesellschaften und zum
beispiel das qualifizierungs chancen
gesetz geht genau in die richtige
richtung um das alter entwickelt
ich finde wenn ich das bei der
gelegenheit sagen darfst auch ganz
besonders charmant dass man da auch mit
den kolleginnen und kollegen der fdp
mittlerweile freundschaftliche darüber
sprechen kann und sie gar nicht
schreiend weglaufen sondern man sich da
auch programme verständigt das genieße
ich sehr und freue mich diesbezüglich
auch auf die zusammenarbeit im ausschuss
dass dann war es ein sehr effektiver
geburtstag sollte man in meinem hohen
alter ja gar nicht meinen wenn wir über
qualifizierung reden müssen wir auch
über berufsausbildung sprechen das ist
völlig klar die krise hat da sehr
eingeschlagen 60.000 ausbildungsplätze
pro jahr weniger auch da bin ich sehr
froh dass es das programm für
ausbildungsplatz sicherheit gab wir
haben eine ganze reihe von themen
vereinbart elternunabhängiges bafög den
freibetrag zu erhöhen und aber auch ganz
besonders im fokus auf die ausbildung im
handwerk zu legen ist ganz wichtig auch
für die industrie da stehen wir auch in
diesem zusammenhang vor großen
herausforderungen und da sind wir auf
einem guten weg wenn wir den
koalitionsvertrag umsetzen
und schließlich stehen auch
selbstständige und freie berufe vor
einer ganz besonderen herausforderung
viele waren lange in der korona zeit und
sind es auch jetzt noch an der ausübung
ihrer tätigkeit gehindert denn auch da
froh dass wir die neustadt hilfe auf den
weg gebracht haben da müssen wir auch
dran bleiben die verlängerung der
überbrückungshilfe 4 kann da wenn es die
gastronomie so betrifft auch
weiterhelfen das ist positiv und die
situation müssen wir im auge behalten
allerdings müssen da auch die frage der
altersvorsorge da bei selbstständigen
nochmal grundsätzlicher diskutieren weiß
nicht ob wir darüber
eine optionale der rentenversicherung
reden wollen oder über das modell der
künstlersozialkasse da brauchen wir aber
noch mehr antworten für mehr als
sicherheit für mehr sicherheit im alter
in zukunft zum abschluss darf ich mich
ganz herzlich beim
bundeswirtschaftsminister bedanken dass
dieser jahreswirtschaftsbericht eben
nicht nur nackte zahlen liefert sondern
gerade soziale und ökologische aspekte
berücksichtigt er ist im besten sinne
des wortes ganzheitlich hat das ganze
land im blick dafür herzlichen dank ich
freue mich auf die umsetzung der
entsprechenden folgen und bedanke mich
für die aufmerksamkeit
ich hoffe sie haben heute noch
gelegenheit ihren geburtstag ein
bisschen zu feiern
nächster redner für die fdp fraktion ist
marc bernhard und er spricht von der
tribüne
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
minister habe ich will die sogenannten
erneuerbaren energien jetzt dreimal
schneller ausbauen bis 20.30 aus der
kohle aussteigen und den co2 preis nie
wieder unter 60 euro fallen lassen herr
minister ist ihnen eigentlich klar was
das für die menschen und die
arbeitsplätze bedeutet ihr ministerium
geht davon aus dass sich unser
strombedarf bis 2030 verdreifachen wird
weil wir künftig auch mit strom fahren
und heizen sollen allein im letzten jahr
wurden elf kohlekraftwerke und drei
kernkraftwerke mit insgesamt neun
gigawatt leistung
abgeschaltet
deutschland ist das einzige land der
welt das
gleichzeitig aus kohle und kernenergie
aussteigt das wall street journal
bezeichnet das als die welt dümmste
energiepolitik
allein allein im grünen regierten
baden-württemberg will der
energieversorger enbw dieses jahr
weitere sechs gigawatt abschalten über
60 prozent des dort benötigten stroms
selbst wenn die grüne landesregierung in
stuttgart die
unrealistisch wunschdenken von 1000
zusätzlichen wind industrie anlagen
realisieren könnte würden diese gerade
mal unzureichende 1,5 gigawatt leisten
so genannte alternativen energien können
den erforderlichen strombedarf also noch
nicht mal nominal
liefern und was machen sie eigentlich
wenn es nacht ist und kein beat w herr
minister man kann ein industrieland eben
nicht allein mit wind und sonne
betreiben
wegen der wegen der strom unterdeckung
warmem tee und chef birnbaum neben
vielen anderen vor der gefahr der
abschaltung ganzer städte also vor
blackouts die
welt dümmste energiepolitik hat dazu
geführt dass wir in deutschland die
höchsten strompreise der welt haben
doppelt so hoch wie in unseren
nachbarländern so zwingen sie
unternehmen ihre produktion und
arbeitsplätze ins ausland zu verlagern
weil wie beispielsweise daimler und basf
nach china weil dort energie sicher und
preiswert ist jedes jahr wird 400
hausrat 400.000 haushalten der strom
abgestellt und 7,4 millionen menschen
frieren in ihren wohnungen weil sie die
hohen energiepreise nicht mehr zahlen
können und die explosion der spritpreise
eine denen der staat rund 60 prozent
kassiert durfte selbst ihnen nicht
verborgen geblieben sein
beenden sie diesen wahnsinn sorgen sie
endlich dafür dass beugen deutschland
niemand mehr frieren und im dunkeln
sitzen muss machen sie schluss mit der
welt dümmsten wirtschaftspolitik
herzlichen dank
nächster redner für die fdp fraktion dr
lukas köhler
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wenn ich von einer sozialen
marktwirtschaft spreche dann meine ich
dass der markt soziales nicht dass der
markt sozial gemacht werden muss das hat
wirklich er hat er schon viel zitiert
und viel bemüht wurde in diese
diskussion gesagt aber ich finde es
zeigt eine ganz interessante sache wir
stehen vor der herausforderung
ökologie ökonomie und die soziale frage
miteinander zu verbinden das ist eine
gigantische herausforderung ich finde
der jahreswirtschaftsbericht zeigt sehr
schön was man alles bedenken muss wenn
man diese herausforderungen angeht wir
stehen vor der frage wie wir eigentlich
ökologie sinnvoll ein preisen wie wir
eigentlich sinnvoll damit umgehen wollen
das innovation und fortschritt gepaart
werden muss mit klaren rahmenbedingungen
und da steht auf der einen seite das was
sie wenn sie sich die bundesbank
anschaut haben oder wenn sie die
einlassung der ezb gehört haben im
moment als green inflation als grüne
inflation betrachte auch der anderen
seite steht wenn sie sich die die
ausführungen hans werner sinn some
gucken das grüne paradox dagegen das
heißt auf der einen seite sagen wir weil
wir energie umbauen wird es teurer wird
jede kilowattstunde teurer
am anfang weil umbaukosten eben david
der anderen seite sagen wir aber dass
fossile energie günstiger weil wir immer
mehr von erneuerbaren energien im markt
sehen werden weil wir immer mehr und das
ist auch gut so erneuerbare energien die
günstig produziert werden die rolle von
fossilen brennstoffen 1 und wie wollen
wir dem entgegnet da gibt es jede menge
antworten die nicht nur der
koalitionsvertrag sondern die auch im
oster paket angekündigt werden die der
wirtschaftsminister an diversen stellen
schon aufgeführt hat und die auch heute
in dieser rede sehr sehr gut dargestellt
hat und der eben darüber gesprochen hat
was es alles zu tun gibt auf der einen
seite haben wir ein klares bekenntnis
zur co2 preise und diese co2 bepreisung
die arbeitet gegen das grüne die
arbeitet dagegen dass fossile energie
immer günstiger wird und nicht fossile
energie genau den unterschied müssen wir
machen dass ich das und wie können wir
das tun indem wir eben ansteuern um
lagen in denen wir eben genau darf sagen
was wir ankündigen und das umsetzen was
wir wollen nämlich die eeg-umlage so
schnell wie möglich abschaffen
und das ist nicht der einzige punkt der
da wichtig denn natürlich spielt der co2
preis die zentrale rolle in dieser frage
wie wir mit dem grün paradox aber eine
ganze menge anderer ideen und
innovationen müssen wir darum herum
bauen und innovationen und ideen die
entwickeln sich eben nur dann wenn es
wettbewerb gibt die entwickeln sich nur
dann wenn der markt seine kräfte
entfalten kann und dazu brauchen wir
rahmenbedingungen die so gewählt sind
das da die beste lösung gefunden wird wo
sie benötigt und das geht eben nur wenn
wir zum beispiel beim klimaschutzgesetz
dafür sorgen dass wir einen
übergeordneten mehrjährigen gesamtrahmen
zur berechnung ist das geht aber auch
nur dann und ist gerade angekündigt
worden wenn wir einströmt neues
strommarkt design finden denn das was in
den letzten jahren jahrzehnten
verschlafen worden ist ist auf die neue
realität einzugehen dass wir ein ganz
anderer art eine ganz andere idee von
stromproduktion haben werden dass wir
verbinden werden wie die innovation bei
erneuerbaren energien gekoppelt wird mit
gas aber am ende des tages geht es um
das ist klargeworden darum dass unsere
wirtschaft weiter wachsen muss damit wir
die innovationskraft die benötigt wird
koppeln können mit der
verteilungswirkung des marktes damit wir
die soziale frage so klären können dass
jeder mensch jeder mensch in deutschland
am ende mehr hat und das geht nur wenn
wir die kräfte des marktes entfesseln
und dafür auch für den bürokratieabbau
wir brauchen den ausstieg aus steuern
umlage vor allen dingen brauchen wir
aber ein jahrzehnte investition in neue
ideen und die müssen klimaneutral sein
und das meine damen ist die
herausforderung der
jahreswirtschaftsbericht für stein und
ich finde es schön finde die idee schön
und es ist auch richtig mehr als nur ein
indikator zu belassen wie die
indikatoren dann miteinander zusammen
verbunden werden das ist etwas das sich
zeigen wird auch dadurch dass die
innovationskraft der märkte beweist was
für lösung für alte problem gefunden
werden können und das entfernen wir
jetzt darauf freue ich mich schon sehr
deswegen vielen dank wir sind ja es
wirtschaftlich
die ihren dank herr kollege liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich grüße sie
an diesem freitag vormittag
und es geht gleich weiter in dieser
debatte
mit hannes walter für die spd-fraktion
und es ist seine erste rede die
deutschen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen bereits seit
1968 legt die bundesregierung gemäß dem
stabilitätsgesetz das ende januar eines
jeden jahres ihren
jahreswirtschaftsbericht vor der bericht
ist so etwas wie das wirtschafts- und
finanzpolitische kurs buchen mitunter
stürmischer see damals wie heute gilt
der ausspruch des früheren
sozialdemokratischen
wirtschaftsministers doktor karl
schiller ich zitiere mit erlaubnis der
präsidentin
der berichte vor allem ein partners die
bundesregierung geht dieses wagnis
bewusstein das risiko nämlich die
glaubwürdigkeit ihrer politik immer
erneut im laufe des jahres beweisen zu
müssen aber glaubwürdigkeit und
reformwillen sind doch wohl wesentlich
für die weiterentwicklung unserer
demokratie
der aktuellen jahreswirtschaftsbericht
mit dem titel für eine sozial
ökologische marktwirtschaft
transformation innovativ gestalten
unterstreicht den reformwillen der ampel
koalition
diese weiterentwicklung unserer sozialen
marktwirtschaft eine stärkere
berücksichtigung von gerechtigkeit und
nachhaltigkeit decken und einen
entsprechenden neuausrichtung
wirtschaftspolitischer instrumente
stehen für ein neues wirtschaften
ich bin zuversichtlich dass wir hier mit
neuen denkansätzen zu einem nachhaltigen
und stetigen wirtschaftswachstum
beitragen
wir bringen unsere wirtschaft durch neue
innovative technologien auf einen
höheren wachstumspfad
doch all das wird uns nicht von heute
auf morgen gelingen daher müssen wir
darauf achten dass wir die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer industrie
von mittelstand und handwerk im hier und
jetzt nicht gefährden nur eine starke
wirtschaft um heute kann die
herausforderungen von morgen meistern
um das zu erreichen brauchen wir
verlässliche rahmenbedingungen im
übergang zu einer emissionsfreien
wirtschaft wir brauchen eine
zuverlässige und bezahlbare
energieversorgung
wir brauchen schnelle planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren
wir brauchen wir brauchen ausreichend
qualifizierte fachkräfte und wir müssen
unnötige bürokratische hürden abbauen
in diesem zusammenhang begrüße ich
ausdrücklich die vereinbarung im
koalitionsvertrag
förderprogramme und
investitionszuschüsse für kmu und
selbstständige in zukunft deutlich
einfacher auszugestalten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen lassen
sie mich abschließend auch auf die
soziale dimension des klimabedingten
strukturwandels eingehen mein wahlkreis
liegt großen teilen in der lausitz seit
über einem jahrhundert liegt die region
von der pole wie in einem brennglas
lassen sich die herausforderungen aber
auch die chancen vor denen unser land
steht in unserer region ablesen für
vorgezogene für vorgezogene
ausstiegspläne brauchen wir eine
schnelle umsetzung der bis sie der
bisherigen zusagen für unsere region
heraus beauftragte der bundesregierung
carsten schneider hat angekündigt dass
zur priorität zu machen das ist richtig
und dafür bin ich ihm sehr dankbar
wir brauchen insbesondere auch eine
gezielte unterstützung für den aufbau
von co2 neutralen wirtschaftsstrukturen
vor ort stichwort wasserstoffwirtschaft
das sind das sind die hochwertigen
industrie arbeitsplätze die wir in der
lausitz brauchen so schön wie unsere
region auch ist und ich lasse sie
wirklich alle einmal die laufer zersägen
länder suchen so sehr schön so schön wie
unser land auch ist vom tourismus
alleine kann unsere region nicht leben
erst wenn alle rahmenbedingungen
insbesondere im strukturwandel und auch
in der versorgungssicherheit stimmen
dann sind wir idealerweise in der lage
über ein kohleausstieg vor 20 38
nachzudenken
neben einem ambitionierten reformwillen
wird es daher immer wieder auch um die
von doktor stiller besagte
glaubwürdigkeit der zu erreichenden
ziele und zeitpläne gehen unsere zukunft
koalition hat das fest im blick hatten
wir es an glück auf
vielen dank die wege weiter
als nächster redner in dieser debatte
fort folgt bernhard los für die cdu csu
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrter
herr dr
sie haben heute ihren
wirtschaftsjahres
jahreswirtschaftsbericht 2022
präsentiert eine mogelpackung ein echter
etikettenschwindel denn sie lösen
inhaltlich nicht das ein was diese
bricht aussagen sollte und die
überschrift ankündigt
eine zentrale bilanz und ein
wirtschaftspolitischer ausblick bei
ihnen ist es ein verschleierungsmittel
und 33 9 und zum teil abenteuerlichen
wirtschaftsindikatoren mit einem
sonderkapitel
überschrieben mit nachhaltiges und
inklusives wachstum dimensionen der
wohlfahrt messbar machen
und mein kollege von der
regierungspartei gibt mir da im center
for edi recht die messlatte der
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung ist und
bleibt aber das bruttosozialprodukt
in landshut und nicht welche parameter
was zum beispiel hat die nitrat
minderung im grundwasser die bildungs
mobilität zwischen eltern und kindern
die frauenquote in führungspositionen
oder der gini koeffizient des einkommens
nach sozialtransfers mit der
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung zu tun was
lässt sich daran ablesen
wir brauchen keinen konsum kritischen
diskurs über den wohlstand sie meinen
damit natürlich auch gut deutsch
nachhaltigkeit sei wichtiger als
wachstum wir die union vor bezweifelt
dies die heftigkeit notwendigkeit diese
sonder kapitels und solche indikatoren
eines jedoch zeigen die wirtschafts
zeichen links gelb hat die wirtschaft in
unserem deutschland in einem soliden
zustand übernommen
das ist die zweite grosse
wirtschaftsdebatte indes ist und gut wie
keine konkreten auskünfte über die
realwirtschaft den mittelstand aber auch
die industrie geben ihr einseitig ist
klima eher einseitige klima fokus ist
falsch und eine gefahr für unsere
wirtschaft dfd faz hat es auf den punkt
gebracht sehnsucht nach dem
wirtschaftsminister
bürgerinnen und bürger aber auch die
wirtschaft erwarten antworten auf die
drängende frage wie geht es
wirtschaftlich weiter
die antwort kann nicht sein verzicht und
verteuerung der energiekosten oder
schaffen sie nicht jetzt die eeg umlage
in wirklichkeit wollen sie doch hohe
energiepreise um ihren klima
kostensenkungen durchzusetzen
transformation der wirtschaft heißt bei
ihnen ideologische demontage der
deutschen wirtschaft zumindest gewisser
herr wirtschaftszweige wie die stahl-
und automobilindustrie
umbau der sozialen marktwirtschaft zu
einer sozialen grünen planwirtschaft ein
vor allem
ökologische ordnungsrahmen das kann
nicht funktionieren
grüner wasser stoffen ist ihre große
lösung der klimafrage mit diesen grünen
wasserstoff soll dann alles betrieben
werden vom auto über das stahlwerk bis
hin zum gaswerk soviel grünen
wasserstoff wie sie verplanen werden wir
aber bezahlbar nicht arbeiten was sagen
sie den produktionsbetrieben den
privathaushalten denen die energiekosten
durch die grüne energie inflation davon
galoppiert wir die union wollen
wohlstand mit nachhaltigem wachstum in
einem klimaneutralen
industrieland deutschland
was ist ihre antwort
abwägung zur nachhaltigkeit und wachstum
unter einem ökologischen ordnungsrahmen
unsere antwort heißt nachhaltiges
wachstum durch innovation danke für die
aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank herr kollege luc
als nächste rednerin erhält das wort die
kollegin dr sandra detzer und es ist
ihre erste rede im deutschen bundestag
für den bis 90 gedreht
sehr verehrte frau präsidentin sehr der
bundeswirtschaftsminister liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wenn ich beim florida zu zugehört habt
dann muss ich an kaiserin zweiten denken
mit seinem ausspruch ich glaube an das
pferd das automobil ist eine
vorübergehende erscheinung dann glaube
ich denn sie stecken geblieben und
deswegen macht es auch an dieser stelle
glaube ich sind wir ein bisschen
grundsätzlicher zu werden
unsere marktwirtschaft ist großartig sie
kann
milliarden entscheidungen einzelner
dezentral organisieren damit sie für die
gesamte gesellschaft das beste
hervorbringen und
ja ihr erfolg gut auf der
innovationskraft dem wissen und der
leidenschaft der einzigen die sich
einsetzen und damit die marktwirtschaft
funktioniert
müssten preise für güter und
dienstleistungen eine signal und eine
lenkungsfunktion haben
preise müssen die wahrheit sagen
die knapp 1 gut ist welche ökologischen
folgen die produktion hat und welchen
sozialen konsequenzen
dann und nur dann wenn preise die
wahrheit sagen kann die marktwirtschaft
funktionieren und kann der markt die
kraft entfalten zum wohl der
allgemeinheit
kurz und gut die marktwirtschaft ist so
gut wie er ordnungspolitische rahmen und
diese ordnungspolitische rahmen ist in
deutschland ungenügend die preise sagen
zu selten die ökologische und soziale
wahrheit atomstrom ist zu billig
gleiches gilt beim kohleabbau und für
die billig schnitzel die marktwirtschaft
hat hier keine chance es muss zu
marktversagen und zu marktverzerrungen
kommen und das ist das problem das wir
haben und es wird inzwischen dazu es
kommen mehr menschen an der kraft der
macht wirtschaft zweifeln und frau
klöckner in ihre richtung will ich damit
sagen ja es sieht ganz wesentlich auch
an ihnen denn sie haben es versäumt das
ansehen der marktwirtschaft zu erhalten
und ihr ein update zu geben sie haben es
für sollen klimaschutz zum
geschäftsmodell zu machen damit haben
sie gemacht wirtschaft geschwächt und
das ist gerade unverzeihlich im harten
globalen wettbewerb
es ist das große verdienst dieses neuen
jahreswirtschaftsbericht dass er diese
schwächen diese gefahren aber auch die
chancen klar benennt
umweltverträgliches soziales
wirtschaften muss immer günstiger sein
als die zerstörung unserer natürlichen
lebensgrundlagen und des
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalts
gewinne zu privatisieren
und kosten zu sozialisieren
das hält auf dauer kein gemeinwesen aus
liebe kollegen und bewegt
ich war vor zwei tagen
eingeladen bei einigen eine keynote zu
halten bei der schleifer tage das sind
ungefähr 120 der weltbesten ingenieure
und techniker innen gewesen aus meinem
wahlkreis ludwigsburg in der region
stuttgart aber bundesweit auf und die
machen sich gerade gedanken viel
gedanken kann ich ihnen sagen mit was
sie in zukunft geld verdienen und sie
haben mir die bitte mit auf den weg
gegeben sagen sie uns was sie brauchen
auf dem weg in eine klimaneutrale
zukunft wir machen es möglich und an der
stelle ganz herzlichen dank für diesen
spirit danke für die ausgestreckte hand
und seien sie versichert genau das
werden wir in dieser ampel koalition zu
herzlichen dank
vielen dank frau kollegin
als nächster redner erhält timon
gremmels für die spd-fraktion das wort
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren wenn man den reden von
herrn spahn vor glöckner und nicht
zuletzt von herrn los so lauscht dann
weiß man das ist ein grund gibt warum
die cdu csu vor den wählerinnen und
wähler in die opposition geschickt
worden meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren bei
das ist nicht die union von morgen das
ist die union voll vorgestern dazu passt
es ja dass herr merz dann demnächst auch
fraktionsvorsitzender werden wird 20
jahre rückschritt wenn dann auch noch
personell dokumentiert von dieser
verehrten damen und ich bin froh dass
die deutsche industrie sehr viel weiter
ist als die cdu csu fraktion reden sie
doch mal mit der deutschen industrie
leben sie doch mal zb die bdi klima fade
studie von 2018 studie von 2021 die auch
die chancen der energiewende des
klimaschutzes für die deutsche
wirtschaft beschreiben und genau das ist
es richtig und genau das müssen wir
starten meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren und daher bin ich die
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
ver dankbar dass er auch zusätzliche
kriterien mit aufgenommen hat und nicht
sich einseitig fixiert auf
wirtschaftswachstum sondern auch
nachhaltigkeitskriterien und ein ganzes
nachhaltigkeits kapiteln aufgenommen hat
das kann man alles google sagt ersparen
aber er hat doch genau das gemacht was
wir hier mal beschlossen haben
siebzehnte wahlperiode es gab eine
enquete kommission für dem begriff
wohlstand wachstum was ist denn da im
abschlussbericht stand da drinnen wir
müssen die soziale und ökologische
dimension von fünf wohlstand abbilden
das haben sie damals mit beschlossen und
genau das macht robert habeck das was
die letzten wirtschaftsminister nicht
geleistet habe macht er sitzt diesen
beschluss dieses dieser enquete
kommission um und sie blockieren dass
man sehr verehrten damen und herren das
ist falsch und das ist nicht der
richtige punkt ich da irgendwie mehr wir
haben das jetzt hier deutschland gemacht
diese kriterien aufgenommen und wir
müssen das auch auf internationaler
ebene umsetzen das bibb ist
internationalen maßstab ich finde es gut
wenn wir auch auf internationaler ebene
nachhaltigkeitskriterien aufnehmen um
wirtschaft zu messen meine sehr
verehrten der mutter wachstum ist nicht
per se schlecht unsere aufgabe muss es
doch sein wachstum vom
ressourcenverbrauch zu trennen das ist
die aufgabe die wir uns stellen müssen
wir brauchen hier nachhaltiges
ökologisches wachstum das ist gut für
den industriestandort deutschland weil
wir mit dem ausbau erneuerbarer energien
auch
exportschlager schaffen wir schaffen
neue jobs wirtschaft neue beschäftigung
und wir schaffen eine nachhaltige
produktion das würde unsere rolle in der
welt stärken meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren das sind unsere chancen und
unser großes problem ist doch dass hier
ein fachkräftemangel in diesem bereich
haben und wer hat das mit zu
verantworten das war auch maßgeblich die
cdu/csu sie haben doch blockiert meine
sachen zuwanderung sie haben blockiert
war spurwechsel sie sorgen dafür dass es
heute zu wenig facharbeiterinnen
facharbeiter gibt gerade im bereich der
energetischen gebäudesanierung meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren das sind
verlorene jahre die wir jetzt nach unten
sind weil sie auf der bremse gestanden
haben und sehr verehrten damen und
herren und lassen sie uns frau
präsidentin zum schluss lassen nämlich
zum schluss kommen ich wir wissen ja
dass robert habeck ein guter autor im
begleitauto ist er hat das mit der
eröffnungsbilanz dem bereich erneuerbare
energien genauso geschafft wie jetzt
beim jahres wirtschaftsprogramm jetzt
gilt es aber dass wir als ampel die
ärmel hochkrempeln und auch liefern die
spd ist dazu bereit ich freue mich auf
die zusammenarbeit vielen dank glück auf
vielen dank herr kollege
als nächstes erhält das wort lisa paus
für bündnis 90 die grünen
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
ich muss es einmal aus mir raus lassen
endlich
nach jahren des rituellen beweihräuchern
von stillstand bei diesen
rituelle sitzungen zum
jahreswirtschaftsbericht
endlich aufbruch
[Applaus]
jahreswirtschaftsbericht ist der erste
der auf räumt der klar ist in der
analyse über die schwierige situation
und der orientierung liefert und frau
klöckner zu ihnen möchte doch noch mal
kurz sagen es wäre gut wenn wir uns auf
die grundrechenarten einigen könnten es
passt einfach nicht zusammen wenn sie
auf der einen seite hier von dieser
bundesregierung fordern mindestens zehn
milliarden euro zusätzlich zu geben für
das für das programm kfw 55 und auf der
anderen seite hier ankündigen dass sie
klagen gegen genau die möglichkeit den
ktf den energie und klimafonds zu
befüllen mit dem geld das wir dann
brauchen würden
dieser
jahreswirtschaftsbericht ist ein
paradigmenwechsel der stellt klar
erstens wohlstand ist mehr als
wirtschaftswachstum zweitens zwischen
wirtschaft und klima gehört kein oder
und drittens diese regierung wird
wirklich alles dafür tun dass wir ein
long cobit der deutschen wirtschaft
vermeiden meine damen und herren
wohlstand ist mehr als wachstum das ist
eigentlich ein allgemeinplatz aber die
debatte heute hat er wieder gezeigt was
uns anscheinend doch für eine revolution
ist im bereich der wirtschaft es ist
völlig absurd dabei ist diese einführung
auf den auf das bild auf das
wirtschaftswachstum allein hält das hat
doch gerade nochmal girona die pandemie
co wird gezeigt beseitigt gesundheit wir
wollen jetzt zusätzlich auch das thema
gesundheit schauen das haben wir eben
nicht getan wir waren viel zu eng mit
der entsprechenden konsequenz da eben
nicht zu sehen dass gesundheit erstens
natürlich das wichtigste ist ohne
gesundheits eigentlich alles andere fast
nichts aber wir sind eben auch eine
ökonomische seite das thema kapazitäten
von tesla ehemalige gesundheitsminister
patienten masken all das das hatten sie
eben nicht im blick weil sie eben nicht
dieses bild haben deswegen müssen das
dringend ändern weil damen und herren
und auch ein recht bildung
auch da hat die alte bundesregierung
bezeichnet kurzsichtig sie waren dass
sie vor allem auf das thema wirtschaft
geschaut haben somit den entsprechenden
drastischen konsequenzen in der
lebensrealität von kindern von schülern
von familien aber auch in der
perspektive für die wirtschaft dann weil
eben ja ganze generationen ganze
schuljahr verloren haben werden mit den
entsprechenden folgen auch für die
wirtschaft noch deswegen ist es wichtig
dass wir insgesamt denken und das eben
wirtschaft nicht nur babys sondern
wirtschaft und wohlstand anders gemessen
wird meine damen und herren
und auch bei sozialen spaltungen
aufdruck hat der minister bereits
gebieten
wir brauchen diese neue form der wenn
sie so wollen rechnungslegung wir
brauchen für die gesamtwirtschaft aber
die brauchen wir auch die
unternehmensebene und deswegen bin ich
froh dass wir im koalitionsvertrag
verankert haben dass wir eine
integrierte nachhaltigkeitsbericht als
das nun einführen wollen meine damen und
herren das macht uns nämlich ein
krisensicherer resistenter und
zukunftsfähig zweitens dieser bericht
stellt klar zwischen wirtschaft und
klima gehört kein oder deutschland steht
vor einer jahrhundertaufgabe damit wir
künftig noch ein leben in freiheit und
wohlstand haben können 80 prozent strom
und 50 wärme aus erneuerbaren energien
bis 2030 eine million ladesäulen im
gleichen zeitraum das wird wirklich kein
spaziergang aber wenn wir es klug
anstellen wenn wir es schaffen das tempo
beim ausbau der erneuerbaren zu
verdreifachen wenn wir den sozial
ökologischen aufbruch mit
planungssicherheit für die wirtschaft
verbinden dann werden sich die
investitionskosten wir jetzt tätigen um
in weniger als zwanzig jahren
klimaneutral zu werden mehr als
rentieren und eines ist auf jeden fall
sicher die kosten eines blinden weiter
so es kommen sie der abschluss von jedem
land ins unermessliche steigen und auch
deswegen steuern wie gegen dieser
jahreswirtschaftsbericht ist ein anfang
wenn wir es gemeinsam anpacken dann
können wir es schaffen braucht kollegen
von twitter zum schluss
[Applaus]
und zum abschluss dieser debatte erhält
falko mohrs das wort für die spd
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin minister
meine damen und herren die deutsche
wirtschaft sie ist leistungsstark sie
ist innovativ und trotz dieser zwei
solchen jahre die wir gerade durchmachen
ist sie auch an vielen stellen in ihrer
substanz noch sehr gut aufgestellt und
jens sparen da muss man eben auch sagen
das bessere ist ja eben auch der feind
des guten und wenn sie auch in der
management der kommune pandemie in
fragen von masken von impfstoff
bereitstellung besser gearbeitet hätten
dann wären wir an dieser stelle auch
besser aufgestellt wenn wir das erbe mit
dem wir alle hier in auch hätten
antreten können noch besser gewählt
gewesen das ist eben auch teil der
wahrheit mit land und
die situation in der wir sind ist aber
auch mit vielen risiken behaftet
wir haben natürlich zuallererst stop and
go in der wirtschaftspolitik durch
störungen in den internationalen
lieferketten wir haben stop and go weil
es eben in den dienstleistungsbereichen
im handel in der gastronomie in der
hotellerie eben durch die korona
pandemie nicht mit ausreichend
perspektive gerade vorangeht wir haben
eine globale angespannte situation wir
haben gestern über die ukraine über
russland diskutiert und wir haben viele
andere herausforderungen die eben auch
in diesem jahr als wirtschaftsbericht
thematisiert werden deswegen ist unsere
kernaufgabe als politik die
rahmenbedingungen für die weitere
entwicklung richtig zu setzen und meine
damen und herren
das muss dann vielleicht auch noch mal
in die richtung der cdu csu sagen
richtige rahmenbedingungen zu setzen ist
übrigens nicht planwirtschaft richtige
rahmenbedingungen zu setzen sorgt dafür
dass es verlässlichkeit das perspektive
und das unterstützung denn und das ist
doch unsere aufgabe und es geht doch
dann auch darum das ist eben nicht nur
auch aber nicht nur um wirtschaft und
klimaschutz sondern eben auch um die
soziale frage dieser veränderung geht es
ist doch unsere kernaufgabe dass die
veränderung dass die transformation vor
der die unternehmen stehen dafür oder so
stattfindet das ist eben nicht auf dem
rücken der arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer
dass wir eben sicherheit in der
veränderung dass wir eben mit der
qualifizierung dafür sorgen dass
beispielsweise mit finde ich sehr wird
starken instrumenten wie eben auch eine
ausbildungsplatzgarantie eine
perspektive für junge leute geschaffen
wird und das sind doch genau die
schlüsse die wir aus dem
jahreswirtschaftsbericht ziehen müssen
das ist doch kein selbstzweck dass wir
diesen bericht hier vorliege meine damen
und herren es geht darum auf grundlage
der guten analyse und auch die richtige
schritte nach vorne zu definieren und
sie eben auch umzusetzen und da geht es
beispielsweise in der kernarbeit der
wirtschaftspolitik darum dass wir im
bereich fachkräfte dafür sorgen dass
menschen die wir hier dringend auf dem
arbeitsmarkt brauchen einwandern dürfen
dass wir es menschen erlauben den
spurwechsel in den arbeitsmarkt
hinzubekommen dass wir es schaffen dass
junge menschen besser ausgebildet werden
und das sind auch die konkreten dinge
die wir hier gemeinsam vorhaben die wir
in unserer koalitionsvertrag auch
geschossen haben und herren und es geht
eben auch in dieser kärnerarbeit der
industrie und der wirtschaftspolitik
darum dass wir ordnungspolitisch also in
fragen des wettbewerbsrechts sowohl auf
der nationalen wie auf der europäischen
ebene die richtigen rahmenbedingungen
setzen und wir haben ja in den letzten
jahren auch wichtige veränderungen
beispielsweise
herbeigeführt damit eben auch die
kleinen die mittelständler dem
wettbewerb mit den großen gerade auch
mit den amerikanische tech unternehmen
mit der konkurrenz aus china aushalten
können und hier wird es darum gehen dass
wir auch weiterhin die richtigen
rahmenbedingungen update meine damen und
herren also
es geht auch darum die richtigen
innovationen und investitionen zu
ermöglichen und frau klöckner das muss
man dann eben auch sagen ihre klage
gegen den nachtragshaushalt
richtet sich im kern gegen die
investitionsfähigkeit unseres landes
damit wir eben diese rahmenbedingungen
für die industrie und für die wirtschaft
hier stellen können die dringend
notwendig sind da brauchen sie nicht den
kopf schütteln das müssen wir einfach
mal für sich auch verarbeiten also meine
damen und herren die industrie die
deutsche wirtschaft sie ist gut
aufgestellt aber die korona krise lastet
die blei auf ihr wir haben verdammt
große rahmenbedingungen die wir setzen
müssen die wir richtig ausrichten müssen
das ist unsere verantwortung der
jahreswirtschaftsbericht zeigt vieles
auf jetzt geht es an die umsetzung
vielen herzlichen dank
vielen dank herr kollege muss ich
schließe die aussprache wir kommen zu
dem entschließungsantrag der fraktionen
der cdu/csu auf drucksache
524 die fraktionen der cdu/csu wünscht
abstimmung in der sache die fraktionen
der spd bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
wünschen überweisung und zwar
federführend an den ausschuss für
klimaschutz und energie und mit beratend
an den wirtschaftsausschuss den
ausschuss für wohnen stadtentwicklung
bauwesen und kommunen und an den
haushaltsausschuss wir stimmen wie immer
zuerst über den antrag auf ausschuss
überweisungen ab und ich frage wer
stimmt für die beantragte überweisung
das ist die spd bündnis 90 die grünen
und die fdp wäre stimmt dagegen das ist
die linke cdu csu die afg enthaltung
keine damit ist die überweisung so
beschlossen und wir stimmen heute
genau bestimmen heute über den
entschließungsantrag auf drucksache 524
nicht in der sache ab so
tagesordnungspunkte 10b und 10c sowie
zusatzpunkte 4 und 5 interfraktionell
wird überweisung der vorlagen auf den
drucksachen
520 160 512 und 402 an die in der
tagesordnung aufgeführten ausschüsse
vorgeschlagen gibt es weitere
überweisungs vorschläge dass es nicht
der fall dann verfahren wir wie
vorgeschlagen
ich rufe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 11
beratung des antrags der fraktionen der
cdu/csu mit dem titel vermarktung
regionaler lebensmittel stärken
agrarexporte ausbauen für die aussprache
ist eine dauer von 31 minuten
beschlossen
wenn sie zügig den sitzplatz wechsel
vornehmen
können wir auch gleich die aussprache
eröffnen
der redner steht schon bereit die
debatte wird eröffnet von alf albert
stegemann entschuldigungen für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen bis zum jahr
2009 sind sie uns fast täglich begegnet
manchmal mehr manchmal weniger bewusst
aber sie waren immer da sprüche wie die
milch macht's ich ernte täglich
komplimente oder butter brauchen sie
alle das alles waren zum beispiel
plakate und damit das ergebnis der
arbeit der cma der centralen marketing
gesellschaft der deutschen
agrarwirtschaft zur absatzförderung
landwirtschaftlicher produkte wie gesagt
kurz cma das funktionsprinzip war
denkbar einfach jeder landwirt gibt von
seinen erlös für sein
landwirtschaftliches produkt einen
kleinen obolus ab um diese mittel zur
absatzförderung zu nutzen leider hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht am dritten
februar 2009 beurteilt dass es sich
hierbei um eine unzulässige sonderabgabe
handelt über ein jahrzehnt später haben
wir aus dem urteil gelernt mittlerweile
gibt es eine machbarkeitsstudie von
agrarökonomen und juristen die im august
2021 neue wege aufgezeigt haben danach
ist es zum beispiel über
branchenorganisationen und
allgemeinverbindlichkeitserklärung
möglich die grundsätzlich gute idee des
agrar marketing sin ein rechtssicheres
konstrukt zu überführen denn die idee
ist nach wie vor richtig da immer
weniger bürger direkt von einem
landwirtschaftlichen betrieb kommen
fehlt einer immer breiter werdenden
bevölkerungsschicht das verständnis
landwirtschaftliche erzeugung und genau
hier könnte eine cma 2.0 ansetzen es
geht also nicht um absatzförderung im
ursprünglichsten sinne sondern auch um
akzeptanz für eine moderne
landwirtschaft diese muss sich nämlich
an realitäten und nicht an nostalgie
ausrichten beides richtig und weiters
ist wichtig denn es geht nicht nur um
wertschöpfung sondern vor allen dingen
um wertschätzung in der landesschau
der aufbau einer agrar marketing agentur
muss dabei hand in hand gehen mit einem
klaren bekenntnis zum agrarexport etwa
ein drittel der gesamtproduktion der
deutschen landwirtschaft wird exportiert
das heißt in der ernährungsindustrie
wird jeder dritte euro im ausland
verdient in der landtechnik sind es
sogar 75 prozent deswegen wirklich auch
noch mal in richtung der
koalitionsfraktion verabschieden sie
sich endlich von ihrer skepsis gegenüber
deutschen agrarexporte erkennen sie an
dass lebensmittel made in germany wegen
ihrer qualität und wegen ihres hohen
standards weltweit gefragt sind erkennen
sie an dass der agrarhandel ein
wichtiges instrument ist um die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit und die
zukunftsfähigkeit der deutschen land und
ernährungswirtschaft zu sichern und
erkennen sie an dass gegenseitige
agrarhandel in der welt zu mehr
nachhaltigkeit führt denn dieser ist ein
wesentlicher bestandteil von
ressourceneffizienz
also stellen sie sich daher an die seite
unserer bäuerinnen und bauern tragen sie
gemeinsam diesen antrag konstruktiv mit
uns und bringen sie das ding in eine
richtige richtung herzlichen dank für
ihr zu hören
vielen dank herr kollege
[Applaus]
als nächste erhält das wort für die
spd-fraktion doktor franziska kersten
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die weichenstellungen für die
landwirtschaft werden jetzt von uns
gestellt wo wollen wir hin und was ist
ziel ihres antrags
green deal und vom volk strategie weisen
und auf europäischer ebene praktisch dem
weg in eine echte nachhaltige
landwirtschaft die klima- und
ressourcenschutz nach hochwertigen
lebensmittel erzeugt und auch einen
guten erzeugt gut bezahlte arbeitsplätze
gestaltet dieses ziel erreichen wir aber
nur wenn wir auf regionale
wertschöpfungsketten achten und wenn wir
uns auf geschlossenen märz steigt
nährstoff kreisläufen berufen lassen sie
mich das kriegs erläutern das große
problem beginnt ja dann bei der
vermarktung denn die landwirtschaft
erzeugt immer vor ort in der region beim
vermarkten wird es schwierig sie können
dann davon ausgeht dass da die
vermarktung das problem ist war die
landwirtschaftsbetriebe nicht frei in
ihrer preisgestaltung sind sie hängen
auch nicht von örtlichen örtlichen
marktbedingungen ab sondern vom
weltmarkt und die getreidepreise werden
zu großen teilen an der börse in chicago
festgelegt wenn dann zur erntezeit nicht
über eigene lager heute verfügt wird
muss man billig verkaufen das ist das
problem und bei den gern gezogen den
vergleichen zur wirtschaft muss ich
sagen es ist der fundamentale
unterschied die abhängigkeit großer
teile der landwirtschaft vom weltmarkt
und um dies zu korrigieren empfehlen
agrarökonomen also ich kenne
wahrscheinlich andere als sie vor allem
auf regionale wertschöpfung zu setzen
verarbeiten
arbeiten veredeln im eigenen betrieb
oder im mittelständischen unternehmen in
der region und zudem auch eine wirklich
entspricht das der vorstellung der
gesellschaft wir wollen mehr einkauf auf
die herkunft der lebensmittel achten
über 82 prozent der verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher haben sich für regionale
herkunft wirklich interessiert gezeigt
regionale erzeugung verarbeitung und
vermarktung sind primäre ziele unserer
kohle koalitionsvereinbarung wir setzen
auch zunehmend auf ökologische
landwirtschaft
wir denken dabei auch an die
heranwachsenden generationen und wollen
daher gesundes essen in den öffentlichen
gemeinschaftsverpflegung gezielt fördern
jedes schul und kita kind so eine
gesunde mahlzeit am tag erhalten können
und da am besten regionale hersteller
nutzen
wenn es uns gelingt auf diesem weg die
regionale produzenten ins boot zu holen
wird dies ein entscheidender beitrag zum
aufbau regionaler märkte für die
einheimischen agrarwirtschaft und zu den
geschlossenen erst als nährstoff
kreisläufen um nachhaltig zu
wirtschaften wird im ackerbau tierischer
dünger benötigt der vor ort durch
entsprechende tierhaltung erzeugt es
dürfen aber nicht links nicht mehr tiere
gehalten werden als boden nährstoffe
aufnehmen kann sonst sehen wir das
problem wie in ihrer region in
südoldenburg die nitratwerte sind nicht
da wo sie hingehören
die in manchen regionen deutschlands
intensiv betriebene
veredelungswirtschaft mit
futtermittelimporten aus südamerika
umweltprobleme durch gesteigerte
emission von treibhausgasen und erhöhte
nitratgehalt die ich gerade schon
erwähnt sind genau das gegenteil von
nachhaltiger landwirtschaft und das
gegenteil von einer gesellschaftlich
akzeptierten tierhaltung
diese mit einer neuen export marketing
agentur zu fördern ist geradezu aus der
zeit gefallen
und noch ein weiterer punkt der mich
beim studium ihres antrags sehr
verwundert hat hauptgrund für die
auflösung der cma war er praktisch diese
dass eine quasi staatliche zell stelle
ausschließlich deutsche agrarprodukte
beworben hat sie haben gerade versucht
es anders darzustellen da was sie
vorhaben aber auch der europäische
gerichtshof hatte es für unzulässig
erklärt und das bundesverfassungsgericht
erklärte 2009 die zwangs wertbeiträge
die ihre landwirtschaftlichen betrieb
wird auch gegen ihren willen praktisch
ablösen mussten die haben die führenden
verfassungswidrig erklärt und das konnte
ihrem antrag nicht entnommen werden wie
sie das lösen wollen
na wollen eine zukunftsfähige
nachhaltige landwirtschaft unserem land
noch ist der zug nicht abgefahren hängen
sie sich dann springen sie rauf wir
wollen nicht auf dem falschen gleis land
und wie das mit dem kino antrag der fall
werden
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau kollegin als nächstes
erhält das wort der kollege bernd
schattner für die afg fraktion und es
ist seine erste rede im deutschen
bundestag
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
der hier vorliegende antrag ist eine
fortführung der misswirtschaft der
agrarpolitik aus den vergangenen 16
jahren unter federführung der union das
sind uns einig dass es den deutschen
agrarsektor nicht gut geht das liegt
aber eben bestimmten nicht daran dass
unsere deutschen betrug die im ausland
unbekannt werden wer die kollegen der
cdu sie schreiben ja selber agrar
produkte made in germany sind im in und
ausland hoch geschätzt und stark
nachgefragt wozu also noch eine neue
agentur die wahren gründe sind doch viel
mehr dass die verfehlte agrarpolitik der
letzten jahrzehnte den deutschen
agrarsektor in ein trümmerfeld
verwandelt hat in den letzten 16 jahren
mussten
133.000 betriebe für immer schließen das
sind 23 betriebe pro tag unter
federführung der unions regierung man
muss sich das einmal ganz konkret vor
augen führen unter ihrer ministerin
klöckner die leider gerade gegangen ist
starb jede stunde ein hof dazu noch
zahlreiche verordnungen die die neue
verordnung oder die blue streifen an den
äckern die das leben unserer deutschen
land werde bestimmt nicht leichter
machen nun beantragen sie eine nationale
marke die cara tour um unsere produkte
im in und ausland bekannter zu machen
ich frage sie bekommen die bauern ein
euro mehr für ihre erzeugnisse durch
diese agentur wie unterstützt diese
agentur den jungen landwirten sie
ackerland erwerben wollen wie schützt
diese agentur verboten spekulanten die
preise für ackerland immer mehr in die
höhe treiben hat ein enger an hektar
ackerland vor 20 jahren noch 1000 euro
gekostet so werden heute regelmäßig mehr
als 20.000 euro verlangt liebe kollegen
der cdu csu das sind doch die fragen und
probleme die wir in unserem land lösen
müssen und eben nicht die schaffung
neuer versorgungsposten in form
nationaler marketing agentur
wir brauchen auch keine neue
werbestrategie um das image der
landwirtschaft zu verbessern es würde
schon reichen wenn die selbsternannten
glühen klimaaktivisten aufhören würden
eine permanente schmutzkampagne gegen
die klassische konventionelle
landwirtschaft zu fahren
und ein letztes
wollen auch sie haben allheilmittel
export mit ihrer verfehlten
exportpolitik treiben sie die landwirte
in den wirtschaftlichen ruin und sorgen
lediglich dafür dass know how und
technik ins ausland abwandert selbst an
clemens tönnies investiert jetzt dank
unerfüllbare auflagen vor ort lieber 75
millionen in einen neuen schlachtbetrieb
in spanien als in deutschland
arbeitsplätze zu schaffen
sehr geehrte damen und herren als af.de
sind wir davon überzeugt dass moderne
bäuerliche betriebe mit verwurzelung in
der region am besten geeignet sind
umwelt- und marktgerecht zu produzieren
ihren antrag zur schaffung einer
nationalen marketingagentur lehnen wir
daher
[Applaus]
vielen dank herr kollege
als nächste erhält das wort doktor anne
monika spallek für bündnis 90/die grünen
und es ist ihre erste rede im deutschen
bundestag
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen letzten samstag
war ich auf dem bäuerin forum der
deutschen landfrauen eine schweine
halterin aus meinem wahlkreis berichtete
von ihrem hof ein klassischer
familienbetrieb seit generationen wir
stehen gerade mit dem rücken an der wand
berichtete sie verzweifelt wir wissen
nicht weiter der hof ist in seiner
existenz akut bedroht die preise im
keller der verlust pro schwein beläuft
sich teils bis auf 70 euro die ursachen
sind bekannt corona schweine steuern
nachfragerückgang aber vor allem china
kauft wegen der afrikanischen
schweinepest kein deutsches
schweinefleisch mehr und stockt auch
selber auf ein ganzer markt an
exportmarkt ist weggebrochen und so
stehen gerade viele
schweinehaltungsbetriebe vor dem aus
dabei haben sie in den letzten 16 jahren
ja nur das umgesetzt was ihn immer
wieder von ihnen gepredigt worden ist
sie haben auf dem weltmarkt gesetz auf
export auf masse auf intensivierung sie
haben zum teil mehrere millionen euro
immer wieder in neue ställe investiert
und sich oft hoch verschuldet und dieses
wachse oder weiche das gilt ja nicht nur
in der landwirtschaft nein es betrifft
die gesamte wertschöpfungskette seit
1998 haben wir etwa 50 prozent aller
nach versorgungsbetriebe verloren
bäckereien fleischereien schlachtereien
mühl und auch gaststätten schlossen
ländliche räume dörfer verödeten in
manchen regionen müssen die einwohner 25
kilometer weit fahren um ein
hinzukaufen und wie wichtig dezentrale
wirtschaftsstrukturen für unsere
versorgungssicherheit sind hat uns
corona doch gerade deutlich vor augen
führt und die selbst versorgungsquote in
deutschland ist schon lange nicht gut
denn die überproduktion der
überproduktion von schweinefleisch steht
ein selbstversorgungsgrad von 20 prozent
bei obst und 38 prozent bei gemüse
gegenüber und sie meine damen und herren
von der cdu csu bringt hier einen antrag
ein der fast ausschließlich wieder auf
export ex agrarexporte bezieht ihr
ansatz ist doch komplett aus der zeit
gefallen wie häufig kann man denn immer
wieder mit dem kopf gegen dieselbe mauer
sie haben in den letzten 16 jahren immer
wieder die export auf dem weltmarkt nach
vorne gestellt und das um jeden preis
mit
katastrophalen folgen für die höfe für
die verarbeitungs strukturen für die
ländlichen räume und für die umwelt das
ergebnis papier der zukunftskommission
landwirtschaft beziffert die externen
kosten der landwirtschaft der deutschen
landwirtschaft auf bis zu 90 milliarden
euro pro jahr und ihre lösung für all
das ist jetzt noch mehr export und eine
marketingagentur die die produkte aus
deutschland in aller welt bewerben soll
das ist alter wein in neuen schläuchen
vor 20 jahren das verfassungsgericht das
quasi von politik und vor allem
das wichtigste hochglanz werbe bildchen
ändern kein krankes system
und der hintern magazine lösen doch die
probleme der landwirtschaft nicht nein
es ist zeit für einen wirklichen
systemwechsel und wir in der ampel
werden die regionalen
wertschöpfungsketten das heißt die
lokale produktion verbunden mit der
lokalen verarbeitung verbunden mit der
lokalen vermarktung vor ort stärken sie
war die gemeinschaftskampagne werden wir
hier eine stabile nachfrage für
regionale und ökologische produkte
schaffen und so werden wir wertschätzung
und wertschöpfung und planungssicherheit
auf die höfe bringen
und so werden wir auch ernährung und
landwirtschaft und umwelt wieder
zusammenbringen und die kreisläufe auch
wieder schließen das bringt auch
verbraucher innen und landrätin wieder
zusammen und die gesellschaftliche
akzeptanz zurück
und ja dazu gehören auch exporte
allerdings nicht zu billigstpreisen die
anderswo in der welt genannt bäuerlichen
betriebe zerstören sondern ökologisch
und sozial nachhaltige qualitäts
erzeugung aus regionaler herkunft und
das wird auch die ländlichen regionen
wieder stärken denn wo es wieder ein
bäcker ein metzger und einen laden vor
ort gibt da begegnen sich menschen
wieder unterwegs der soziale
zusammenhalt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen unser
ziel sind lebendige ländliche räume mit
einer vielzahl an höfen und betrieben
des lebensmittelhandwerk wer die ampel
werden den nötigen aufdruck dazu jetzt
gestalten und es wäre schön wenn die
cdu/csu sich dieser transformation jetzt
anschließen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
als nächstes folgt in dieser debatte für
die fraktion die linke in latendorf
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
frau dr spallek hat schon vieles gesagt
was ich auch sagen wollte aber dennoch
der vorliegende antrag fängt mit der
vermarktung regionaler lebensmittel gut
an und lässt dann aber mit ausbau der
agrarexporte stark nach ein ansinnen als
hätte es die zukunftskommission
landwirtschaft nie gegeben auch
aussuchen der exporttätigkeit wie hier
verlangt ist im zeitalter von
klimawandel und nachhaltigkeit nicht
angebracht wichtiger als mehr export
heimische lebensmittel zu fordern ist es
die weitgehende selbstversorgung in
deutschland herzustellen dadurch würden
kurze lieferketten ermöglicht und
erzählt vom erzeuger bis zum konsumenten
der ausbau regionaler
verarbeitungs und
vermarktungsunternehmen wäre
selbstverständlich eine förderwürdige
idee aber der export auf teufel komm
raus über das maß hinaus das es jetzt
schon gibt da sagen wir nein nicht mit
uns
wir wollen gerade den grad der
selbstversorgung erhöhen dieser liegt
bei obst und gemüse wir haben es gerade
gehört nur bei 30 prozent apple aus
übersee durch subventionierte abkommen
sind zum teil billiger als die
einheimischen aber sie sind ökologisch
fragwürdig lange lieferketten kühlung
lagerung usw im zweifel haben diese
äpfel natürlich nicht mehr vitamine und
nährstoffe als die heimischen aus dem
alten land und diese philosophie ist
übertragbar leinsamen stadt hier erbsen
stadt so ja wir müssen umstellen also
die stärkung der inlandsproduktion für
den heimischen devise sein viele dringen
nach es den export anzukurbeln muss die
marktstellung der landwirte und
landwirtinnen verbessert werden den vier
größten händlern der lebensmittel des
lebensmitteleinzelhandels in der
vermarktung stehen etwa 200
63.500 landwirtschaftliche betriebe
gegenüber und wer diktiert den preis
nicht die landwirte der vorliegende
antrag ignoriert das notwendigste die
landwirtschaft braucht jetzt die
zusicherung dass die produkte nicht mehr
unterhalb der produktionskosten ab
verkauft und hier im land konsumiert
werden vielen dank für aufmerksamkeit in
latendorf war das für die linksfraktion
und nächster redner in der debatte um
eine um die vermarktung regionaler
lebensmittel ist ingo bothge er sitzt im
ausschuss für landwirtschaft und
ernährung für die fdp-fraktion und
spricht jetzt hier im deutschen
bundestag zum ersten mal
[Applaus]
sehr gerne frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren
gestatten sie mir ein paar einleitenden
bemerkungen
es ist eine ganz besondere ehre für mich
hier an diesem platz zu stehen und zu
ihnen zu sprechen
am 10 november 1989 habe ich nur wenige
meter von ihr am brandenburger tor mein
ganz eigenes stück von der mauer
abgeschlagen
es war ein ganz besonderes gefühl
und heute hier zu stehen
ist noch einmal etwas
besonderes
bieten
aber nun zu diesem vorliegende antrag
die cdu csu fordert dass eine staatliche
ak marketing agentur gegründet werden
soll um deutsche produkte der land und
ernährungswirtschaft
verstärkt international auf eu-ebene und
weltweit zu bewerben
bekanntlich sind unsere hochwertigen
lebensmittel im in und ausland sehr
geschätzt und es gibt weltweit kaum ein
land das eine solche
lebensmittelqualität im einklang mit
derartig hohen standort tirol
nachhaltigkeit erzeugt wie deutschland
die fdp hat gemeinsam mit ihren
koalitionspartnern im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart den anteil regionaler
erzeugnisse entsprechend der ausbauziele
zu erhöhen wir wollen unsere verbraucher
und deutschland noch stärker motivieren
regional erzeugte deutsche lebensmittel
zu kaufen es ist nicht nur im sinne des
verbrauchers im feinkostladen
deutschland einzukaufen
sondern nutzt auch
unseren power
sie fordern im antrag die errichtung
einer agrar marketing agentur nach dem
vorbild das ehepaar
bekanntlich müsste die centrale
marketing-gesellschaft nach dem urteil
des bundesverfassungsgerichts im jahr
2009 liquidiert werden weil ein privat
finanziert exportförderung mit
zwangsabgaben als nicht
verfassungskonform
erachtet wurde sehr geehrte damen und
herren der union ich frage mich
warum haben sie unter der
unionsgeführten bundesregierung nicht
schon längst eine nachfolgeorganisation
für die cma
installiert
warum haben sie die letzten 13 jahre
regierungsverantwortung mit
agrarministern von cdu und csu nicht
genutzt um eine neue staatlich
finanzierten marke vermarktung im sinne
dieses tags aufzubauen
warum stellen sie dann gerade jetzt aus
der parlamentarischen opposition heraus
diese forderung
ich kann es ihnen sagen sie
wussten dass sie aus bundesmitteln nicht
finanzierbar worden sie wussten schon
damals dass der einzelplan des
bundesministeriums für ernährung und
landwirtschaft um 100 millionen euro pro
jahr aufgestockt werden müsste
auch die restmittel in höhe von 100
millionen euro aus der liquidation der
absatzfonds der cma dürfte allenfalls
für eine anschubfinanzierung reichen die
laufen die handlichen kosten liegen dann
aber auch bei etwa 100 millionen
natürlich ist das aus der
oppositionssicht komfortabel eine
derartige forderung zu stellen ohne
darzulegen wo das geld dafür herkommen
soll ich vermisse im vorigen antrag ein
seriöses finanzierungskonzept
die fdp steht für bürokratieabbau und
entlastung der bürger
mit der gründung einer staatlich
finanzierten ak marketingagentur konnten
wir eine neue bundesbehörde mit vier
neuen bundesbeamten geschaffen und damit
steuergelder in millionenhöhe
versenkt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der union
ihr antrag hört sich zunächst sehr wohl
klingen dann ist aber bei genauer
betrachtung
eine politische luftnummer
jetzt eine forderung aufzustellen
von der sie seit 13 jahren in der region
wussten dass sie aus bundesmitteln nicht
zu finanzieren ist hat nichts aber auch
gar nichts mit einer konstruktiven
oppositionsarbeit zu tun viel schlimmer
mit solchen anträgen so tun als ob nicht
eher die letzten eineinhalb jahre und
jahrzehnte für die landwirtschaft
verantwortung getragen hat ist lange
noch nicht in der rolle opposition in
diesem hohen hause an die kunden vielen
dank
vielen dank
als nächste erhält das wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion die kollegin christina
stumpf und es ist ihre erste rede im
deutschen bundestag
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
hochwertige aber bezahlbare lebensmittel
nicht nur mehr wertschätzung sondern
wertschöpfung für die bäuerinnen und
bauern schöne worte die der minister in
seiner agenda hat fallen lassen das
unterschreibe ich gerne aber wie das
funktionieren kann dazu schweigt der
minister
dabei liegt die lösung wörtlich nahm
nichts liegt näher als lebensmittel aus
der unmittelbaren region der menschen
der landwirtschaft und der landwirte vor
ort produziert der landwirt vor ort
produziert hochwertige erzeugnisse und
steht für ihre qualität mit seinem guten
namen als jemand der auf einem
landwirtschaftlichen familienbetrieb
groß geworden ist weiß ich mit wie viel
engagement herzblut und innovativen
ideen hier gearbeitet wird
regionalität bedeutet auch kurze
transportwege
das ist ökologisch sinnvoll und spart
zugleich kosten direkte vermarktung und
weniger zwischenhändler bedeuten mehr
geld für unsere landwirte
qualitätsprodukte aus der region das ist
es auch was sich unsere verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher heute wünschen
82 prozent sagen dass die regionale
herkunft von lebensmitteln
ein wichtiges auswahlkriterium bei ihrer
kaufentscheidung darstellt diese chance
wollen wir nutzen
regionale lebensmittel genießen erstens
bei den verbraucherinnen verbraucher ein
hohes maß an vertrauen sie stehen
zweitens für transparenz frische und
qualität und drittens noch
entscheidender sie stärken die
wertschöpfung in den ländlichen regionen
und tragen zu erhalt unserer
kulturlandschaft bei über gutes von hier
gut reden das muss unser ansatz sein
in der kommunikation entlang der
wertschöpfungsketten vom erzeuger bis
zum verbraucher können und müssen die
vorzüge unserer heimischen
landwirtschaft
hervorkommen und damit der verbundenen
mehrwert noch stärker betont werden dass
mehr an qualität an genuss an frische
ist aber auch ein mehr an arbeit wie das
positiv begleitet werden kann konnte ich
an meiner alten wirkungsstätte sehen das
cdu-geführte
landwirtschaftsministerium in baden
württemberg hat bereits 2017 die
regional kampagne natürlich von daheim
gestattet die landwirtschaft bekommt
hier ein gesicht und wird für den
verbraucher erlebbar gemacht
meine damen und herren ein wichtiger
ansatz für uns als cdu csu fraktion zur
stärkung unserer agrar und
ernährungswirtschaft ist neben dem
ausbau regionaler wertschöpfungsketten
auch die erschließung neuer märkte im
ausland
gerade unseren kleinen und mittleren
landwirtschaftlichen betrieben wollen
wir bei der vermarktung ihrer
hochwertigen lebensmittel unterstützen
deshalb brauchen wir ein agrar marketing
agentur die den qualität made in germany
auch über unserer landwirtschaft
leuchten lässt liebe damen und herren
wir stärken mit unserem antrag die
zukunftsfähigkeit unserer höfe und
sorgen zugleich dafür dass hochwertige
lebensmittel in zukunft auch bezahlbar
bleiben
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau kollegin
und als nächste erhält das wort
natalie public und auch für sie ist es
die erste rede im deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren
als ich in meinen ersten sechs
lebensjahren im tiefsten sibirien auf
einem kleinen selbstversorger bauernhof
aufgewachsen bin hätte sich niemand aus
meiner familie auch noch vorstellen
können dass ich einmal meine erste rede
im deutschen bundestag zur agrarpolitik
halten
die wenigsten landwirte heute sind wie
wir damals selbstversorger doch noch
immer ist die regionale landwirtschaft
in ihrer vielfalt eine tragende säule
unserer gesellschaft tag für tag
versorgen uns menschen in der
landwirtschaft mit lebensmitteln die
meisten betriebe sind
familienunternehmen sie gestalten den
ländlichen raum wie kein anderer
wirtschaftszweig
in meinem wahlkreis denn der hessischen
wetterau finden sie zahlreiche betriebe
die clevere ideen der direkt vermarktung
ihrer produkte umsetzen und nicht
aufhören sich zu entwickeln um gute
landwirtschaftliche erzeugnisse an die
konsumenten zu bringen nur gemeinsam mit
den landwirtinnen und landwirten als
partner schaffen wir es die
herausforderung des klima und
strukturwandels unserer zeitung die welt
ich bin froh dass wir mit der neuen
koalition und dem personalwechsel an der
spitze des bundesministeriums für
ernährung und landwirtschaft den fokus
endlich wieder auf eine sozial gerechte
ökonomisch und ökologisch zukunftsfähige
landwirtschaft legen
wir machen fortschrittliche politik auf
höhe der zeit war wir landwirtschaft und
klimaschutz zusammenführen und sie mit
einer fortschrittlichen politik
verbinden statt gegeneinander
auszuspielen
[Applaus]
der klimawandel und internationale
lieferketten verlangen gerade von den
familiengeführten betrieben viel ab es
ist wichtig dass wir als bundesrepublik
gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
partnern
nachhaltigkeit fairen handels und
produktionsbedingungen und soziale
standards in der landwirtschaft
europäisch und global voranbringen
dumping und unfaire handelsbedingungen
raum die existenzgrundlagen sowohl den
bauern in deutschland als auch
denjenigen deren märkte mit exzessiven
agrarexporten überflutet werden
staatlich geförderter agrarexport
mangels eigener absatzmöglichkeit
zerstört viel zu oft regionale märkte
ein massiver ausbau von agrarexporten
verschärft die probleme gerade in den
ländern des globalen südens es ist kein
beitrag zur lösung
was mich aber noch viel mehr stört dass
ihre und reflektierte haltung zu
exporten liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der cdu csu in den letzten 16 jahren
wurde das bundesministerium für
ernährung und landwirtschaft
durchgehend durch ihre partei besetzt 16
jahre in denen sie zeit gehabt hätten
die sozialen bedingungen in der
landwirtschaft zu verbessern das massive
höfesterben zu stoppen und für mehr
nachhaltigkeit zu sorgen
klöbner in der letzten legislatur auf
das ein oder andere treffen mit nestlé
und co verzichtet und stattdessen
politik für die regionale landwirtschaft
gemacht da wären wir heute einen großen
schritt weiter
es ist gut dass die ampel koalition eine
wende aus ihrer veralteten politik
einläutet und gemeinsam mit der
landwirtschaft für fortschritt sorgt
herzlichen ganz viel ausmachen
die erste rede von matellia blick aus
der spd-fraktion sie unter anderem wie
das system der landwirtschaft
angesprochen hat auch das ist hier immer
wieder thema wie auch die landwirte
unterstützt werden können dass sie gut
entlohnt werden für ihre arbeit wir
kommen zur letzten rede in dieser
debatte das ist max straubinger von der
unionsfraktion
geschätzte frau präsidentin werden die
kolleginnen und kollegen
frau kollegin public sie sind ja die
letzten jahre nicht dabei gewesen aber
uns hat er ständig die spd begleitet als
er in der regierungsarbeit und da haben
wir in der regel nur erlebt dass wenn es
um internationale abkommen geht wenn zum
tag gegen wenn zum tipp gehen wenn es um
die abkommen mit japan ging letztendlich
die spd immer auf der bremse stand damit
ging natürlich haben wir nix weiter
ratec kolleginnen und kollegen an jetzt
ist es geht es uns auch um den
agrarexport der enorm wichtig ist für
uns für die bäuerinnen und bauern ein
dritter ein dritter der produzierten
güter gehen in den export und das
bedeutet aber nicht dass wir die
exportmärkte überschwemmen würden
sondern im gegenteil der import von
agrarprodukten ist wesentlich höher ist
wie der export in deutschland und das
ist mit die entscheidende frage und das
hilft auch entwicklungsländern frau
kollegin künast und da gehört mit dazu
dass wir natürlich werbung betreiben für
unsere hochqualitativen lebensmittel ich
erinnere daran es gibt den schönen
spruch wer nicht wirbt der stirbt und
das bedeutet letztendlich mit einer
agrarmarketing struktur können wir hier
unterstützt für unsere die mittel werden
und dementsprechend grundlagen schaffen
für unsere bäuerinnen und bauern dass
sie eine gute existenz mit haben können
und dies haben wir mit den vergangenen
jahren mehr zustande gebracht ich
erinnere an werbesprüche wie zb aus
deutschen landen frisch auf den tisch
also das bedeutet regionalität für uns
für die bürgerinnen und bürgern hohe
qualität ich erinnere an den schönen und
guten spruch werden die grünen natürlich
nicht mittragen aber ich stehe dazu
fleisch ist ein stück lebenskraft hieß
es einmal oder das war mit etwas sehr
wichtiges und entscheidendes bevor
lassen aminosäuren in der veganen
ernährung und sonst und zusätzlich
tätigen muss ist es besser also hier ein
stück fleisch zu konsumieren liebe frau
kollegin kühn aus der zimmer und
das bedeutet auch dass der export und
nachhaltige
lebensmittel erzeugung keine gegensätze
sind sondern im gegenteil es geht ja
darum zum beispiel bei einem stück
fleisch oder ein stück ein schwein zu
vermarkten da geht es um alle teile wenn
in deutschland die bürger hauptsächlich
schnitzel konsumieren wollen zur musik
eben feststellen dass ein ganzes schwein
nicht nur als schnitzer besteht als
damals und das alles egal vielleicht
auch sagen wir hier ist es
offensichtlich nicht und das bedeutet
letztendlich das größer klaren füßchen
und sonstiges das in anderen entfernten
märkten gerne aufgenommen wird
dementsprechend dann auch bedient werden
müssen diese märkte und das ist unser
agrarexport der damit eine unterstützung
bekommen würde deshalb kann ich fertig
kolleginnen und kollegen der
regierungsfraktionen und vor allen
dingen auch den kollegen der fdp die
sind ja früher auf serbien agrarexport
gewesen leider gottes hat der kollege
der für die fdp bekommen sie beschlossen
hatte aufgelegt also ich bin noch völlig
verdutzt gewesen keine unterstützung
mehr für die deutschen bäuerinnen und
bauern sondern im gegenteil
abbruchunternehmen hat sich die fdp hier
generiert für die bäuerinnen und bauern
das ist letztendlich die konsequenz und
deshalb stimmen sie unserem antrag zu
dann tun sie was gutes für die
bäuerinnen und bauern in deutschland
vielen dank ich schließe die aussprache
interfraktionell wird überweisung der
vorlage auf drucksache 206 an die in der
tagesordnung aufgeführten ausschüsse
vorgeschlagen gibt es weil es bedeuten
dort wird der antrag dann nochmal
diskutiert und dann wieder hier ins
plenum
diskutiert wir kommen damit zu einem
komplett anderen thema es geht um den
bundeswehreinsatz im irak vor zwei
wochen hatte der bundestag darüber fiel
schon
diskutiert das mandat soll bis zum 31
oktober verlängert werden so der wunsch
der bundesregierung 500 deutsche
soldatinnen und soldaten
wir sollen dafür eingesetzt werden
können vielleicht gibt es ja ein bis der
bundestag hatte ende oktober 2020 eine
mandatsverlängerung ist januar 2022
beschlossen also bis ende januar das
heißt das mandat läuft jetzt aus damals
hatten sich die grünen noch gegen diesen
einsatz
ein
ausgesprochen und hier wurde eben eva
högl auch begrüßt die liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen das bundes wehrbeauftragte
des bundestags die hört hier auch zu
und diese würden wir hoffen sie auch eva
högl ist jetzt hier auch in welt die 50
zusagen als anwalt welt in auch
bezeichnet wird der deutschen
soldatinnen und soldaten erste rednerin
ist jetzt sara nanni
verteidigungspolitische sprecherin der
grünen fraktion
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die bundeswehr
ist eine parlamentsarmee
wir können im bundestag über ihren
einsatz entscheiden das ist im
internationalen vergleich nicht
selbstverständlich aus diesem recht
ergibt sich aber auch eine pflicht
nämlich die pflicht genau hinzuschauen
auf das land in dem wir engagiert sind
und auf die menschen und auf die
soldaten die dort ihren dienst leisten
der irak leidet nach wie vor unter dem
terror des sogenannten islamischen
staates die bedrohung ist zwar nicht
mehr zu vergleichen mit der wie sie sich
vor ein paar jahren dargestellt hat als
ein territorium teile von syrien und
teile von irak de facto von einer terror
organisation regiert wurden aber die
herausforderung bleiben trotzdem riesig
und deshalb ist das ziel des engagements
stabilität und sicherheit zu fördern
richtig
es gibt zwei änderungen im mandat die es
wesentlich verbessern und auf ein
solideres fundament stellen erstens
fokussiert sich das mandat ruhen auf den
irak syrien ist als mandatsgebiet
ausgeworfen und zwei punkte schließen
wir mit dem mandat dass wir es um
fassung evaluieren werden und das ist
neu
wir haben uns das als ampel für alle
mandate vorgenommen das irak mandat ist
das erste bei dem dieses vorhaben zur
anwendung kommen wird das ist gut
richtig und wichtig und ich freue mich
sehr darauf diese prozess der evaluation
auch hier im parlament zu begleiten
der deutsche einsatz in iraks findet in
zwei unterschiedlichen kontexten stadt
in der nato mission in iraq und in der
so genannten erst koalition es ist kein
geheimnis dass wir als grüne mit der
koalition der willigen die die anti erst
koalition nach wie vor da stellt ein
grundsätzliches problem hatten an der
politischen bewertung dass solche
einsätze besser im rahmen von sich die
systemsicherheit
systemen kollektiver sicherheit
stattfinden soll hat sich nichts
geändert und ich bin sehr froh dass sich
die ampelkoalition dieser auffassung
durch den koalitionsvertrag auch
angeschlossen hat
nur den rahmen eines multinationalen
einsatz ändert man nicht in sechs wochen
regierungszeit und das was die menschen
in iran brauchen ist verlässlichkeit
auch unsere es sind nach wie vor
herausfordernde zeiten die wahlen sind
technisch und von den abläufen her
gelungen politisch ist die
regierungsbildung bildung allerdings
immer noch mehr als schwierig die
sicherheitskräfte sind heute besser
aufgestellt und noch vor einiger zeit
als noch vor einiger zeit trotzdem
können anschläge des nicht vollständig
verhindert werden und sie mehren sich
sogar auch gegen die sicherheitskräfte
selbst
die leichten verbesserung der
beziehungen zwischen der
zentralregierung und der regierung in
nord irak sind in ihrer politischen
bedeutung nicht zu unterschätzen
trotzdem bleibt es dabei sie sind
schwierig und es gibt akteure die ethno
politisieren den konflikt weiter und
sind nicht auf kooperation und
versöhnung aus hier weiter an der seite
der menschen in irak zu stehen ist mehr
als ein wichtiges zeichen auch für die
region
der einsatz leistet einen beitrag zur
stabilisierung und ermöglicht das
humanitäre hilfe
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und die
zivile arbeit die arbeit leisten kann
dies leisten muss damit es
perspektivisch aufwärts geht die
deutschen soldatinnen befinden sich in
irak in einem gefährlichen
sicherheitsumfeld ihr beitrag ist auch
was die entbehrung im privaten rangeht
nicht zu unterschätzen ihnen gilt unser
ausdrücklicher dank
[Applaus]
leider konnte ich vor der verlängerung
des mandats die truppe vor ort noch
nicht besuchen sobald das möglich ist
möchte ich das tun die ministerin und
auch unsere ausschussvorsitzender waren
schon da und ich finde das ist nicht nur
ein wichtiges zeichen der anerkennung
sondern auch essenziell für das was
jetzt auf uns zukommt
werden unser job zum irak endet nicht
mit dem beschluss dieses mandats unser
job als parlament wird es sein nicht
erst wieder dann hinzuschauen wenn es um
die verlängerung geht sondern schon die
ganze zeit dazwischen das haben die
menschen in dierath das haben unsere
soldaten verdient dazu lade ich sie
herzlich ein bitte heute um ihre
zustimmung zu diesem ein dankeschön
vielen dank frau kollegin anni
es folgt nun
für die cdu/csu-fraktion der kollege
doch per norbert röttgen
die norbert röttgen in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode den ausschuss den
ausschuss geleitet ist jetzt
niederzulegen und kollegen die cdu csu
fraktion stimmt dem antrag der
bundesregierung den irak einsatz der
bundeswehr fortzusetzen zu der
islamische staat hat erfreulicherweise
keine gebiets kontrolle mehr im irak
aber er ist immer noch eine gefährdung
des friedens und der stabilität im irak
selber ist es sieht es besser aus als
lange zuvor aber der irak ist weiterhin
fragil er braucht weiter internationale
stabilisierungs unterstützung
dass man das was leute beschließen ist
praktisch die fortsetzung des bisherigen
einsatzes des bisherigen mandates es
gibt eine kleine textliche anpassung an
die realität des einsatzes nämlich die
beschränkung des einsatzgebietes auf den
irak das war die realität des einsatzes
jetzt ist es auch die textliche fassung
des mandates das aber nicht wesentlicher
weise schon immer die realität war die
cdu csu fraktion hat als
regierungsfraktionen diesem dem antrag
der bundesregierung zugestimmt und wir
stimmen jetzt als oppositionsfraktion
dem antrag der bundesregierung zu wir
stimmen zu außenpolitischer
verantwortung unsere außenpolitische
verantwortung ist unabhängig davon
welche parlamentarische rolle die
cdu/csu-fraktion fragen
es gibt es gibt zwei veränderungen auf
die ich eingehen möchte eine hier bei
uns im haus und eine außenpolitische
veränderung die im haus besteht darin
dass die fraktion der grünen jetzt als
regierungsfraktion
dieses mandat als regierungs teil der
regierung einbringen und als
regierungsfraktion auch zustimmen als
die oppositionsfraktion waren haben sie
immer gegen diesen antrag gegen den
antrag der bundesregierung gestimmt und
zwar aus verfassungsrechtlichen und
völkerrechtlichen gründen ich erwähne
das gar nicht mit irgendeiner form der
helme der anpassung der rechtlichen
auffassung an die an die tatsächlichen
rechtlichen auffassung an die
parlamentarische rolle das tue ich nicht
sondern ich erwähne es um positiv und
wenn sie den kurswechsel vornehmen das
will ich dann doch sagen weil sie so
reagiert dann sollten sie auch zu ihm
stehen sie sollten dann transparent sein
sie sollten sagen wir haben unsere
meinung geändert das ist legitim in der
politik aber sie sollten sich nicht
beschweren dass wenn ein meinungswechsel
vorgenommen wird durch sie darauf auch
sich andere fraktionen erlauben darauf
hinzuweisen dass sie jetzt eine neue
meine platte das meine ich muss erlaubt
sein
ich wollte es ausschließlich positiv
darstellen und bleibe auch bei meiner
positiven darstellung weil die
konsequenz ihres kurswechsels jetzt
darin besteht dass der
verfassungsrechtliche und
völkerrechtliche konsens über diesen
bundeswehreinsatz und damit auch
vergleichbare
bundeswehreinsätze
breiter geworden ist wir haben jetzt
einen konsens dieser fraktionen mit
ausnahme der linksfraktion der afg
fraktion über die verfassungsrechtliche
und völkerrechtliche bewertung das
bewerte ich positiv weil dieser
außenpolitischen konsens eine stärke
unseres landes ist das war der punkt
warum muss er wählen kann
das ist der grund warum ich auch hier
ausdrücklich für das protokoll den
antragstext den wir jetzt fraktionen
vier fraktionen zustimmen zitiere damit
klar ist was unsere
verfassungsrechtlichen völkerrechtliche
auffassung nun hier gemeinsam ist ich
zitiere aus dem antrag ziffer 2 letzter
absatz verfassungsrechtliche grundlage
für den einsatz ist artikel 24 absatz 2
des grundgesetzes
der einsatz erfolgt hinsichtlich seiner
zielrichtung der unterbindung eines
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff vom bs
sowie der herstellung des weltfriedens
und der internationalen sicherheit im
rahmen und nach den regeln eines systems
kollektiver sicherheit den vereinten
nationen das ist jetzt unsere gemeinsame
verfassungsrechtliche und
völkerrechtliche auffassung ich begrüße
sehr dass wir diese zustimmung im haus
unter den demokratischen fraktionen
erzielt haben ich möchte einen zweiten
punkt erwähnen der veränderung der uns
arbeit und aufgabe aufgibt und das ist
eine außenpolitische veränderung die
wesentliche außenpolitische veränderung
besteht darin dass die vereinigten
staaten von amerika die region des nahen
mittleren ostens im allgemeinen und den
irak im besonderen nicht mehr als ihre
außenpolitische priorität betrachten ist
ein wesentlicher kurskorrektur wir sind
in afghanistan wir sehen uns jetzt auch
im irak es wird es gibt keinen
amerikanischen kampfeinsatzes gibt ob
ein kampfeinsatz der nato mehr das ist
rückzug der usa aus der region es ist
die fokussierung der usa die neue
bestimmung ihrer prioritäten und vor
allen dingen auf schiene
die frage ist was bedeutet das für
deutschland was bedeutet das für europa
wir haben vor allen dingen in der
sogenannten flüchtlingskrise gelernt
dass wir die sicherheit in deutschland
die sicherheit in europa nicht von der
sicherheitslage im nahen und mittleren
osten trennen können wir deutsche
deutschland europa hat nicht das
privileg entscheiden zu können dass uns
diese nachbarregion nicht interessiert
und nicht mehr unsere priorität ist und
darum bedeutet der rückzug der usa für
uns die frage die wir beantworten müssen
was ist die strategie deutschlands die
außenpolitische strategie deutschland
europas für diese nachbarregion die für
unsere sicherheit essentiell und
existenziell ist die frage harte
beantworten jeder bundeswehreinsatz ist
nur so gut wie das außenpolitische
konzept in das er eingebettet ist gut
ist und diese strategische antwort auf
die einbettung dieses einsatzes fehlt
sie muss geliefert werden der antrag ist
befristet zum ende oktober dann werden
wir neu bestimmen und bis dahin ist auch
mit dem antrag geht es für neun monate
da kommen sie bloß ist die zeit gekauft
diese strategische frage was ist das
politische konzept des bundeswehr
einsatzes für den irak und die region zu
beantworten wir müssen diese antwort
liefern in unserem eigenen
sicherheitsinteresse in acht monaten
sehen wir uns wieder und dann warten wir
auf die antwort der regierung wir werden
auch unsere antworten geben und wir
würden uns freuen wenn wir zu einer
starken übereinstimmung in dieser frage
kommen vielleicht
norbert röttgen einer politischen
strategie an jetzt gibt es eine
kurzintervention von jürgen trittin den
grünen
durchaus zur kenntnis genommen
dass sie hier ohne häme argumentieren
wollten
aber da wir über protokoll und ähnliches
sprechen muss ich sie auf zwei dinge
hinweisen
wir haben dieses mandat weil es
eingeschlossen hat
operationen
der bundeswehr über einen souveränen
staat
für völkerrechtswidrig gehalten
und genau dieses haben wir substanziell
aus diesem heraus gestrichen das ist
keine textliche änderung sondern das
festhalten an unserer
völkerrechtlichen position
ich komme zu einem zweiten punkt wir
haben auch verfassungsrechtliche
einwände was das agieren außerhalb eines
bündnisses kollektiver sicherheit angeht
und dieses problem haben wir abzuwägen
dagegen
dass wir
keine plötzliche veränderung in einem
einsatz wollten wo wir die ausbildung
von soldatinnen und soldaten im nordirak
und auch im zentraliran und wir haben
andere parteien hier im hause dafür
kritisiert dass es nicht unter dem dach
der nato geschehen ist nicht aufgegeben
sondern wir haben dies ausdrücklich
davor fath von nanni vorhin hingewiesen
zum gegenstand der evaluierung gemacht
aber in der abwägung ob wir aus diesem
grunde nicht neun monate warten können
oder rausgehen haben wir uns dafür
entschieden das anliegen was wir immer
für richtig gefunden haben auch weiter
zu machen und deswegen gebe ich hiermit
offiziell zu protokoll wir haben auch
unsere verfassungsrechtliche position
nicht geändert
der außenpolitische sprecher der grünen
für die tricks und war das mit einer
kurzintervention jetzt kann eine
erwiderung von
norbert röttgen fallen
frau präsidentin kolleginnen kollegen
pflege trittin ich bedauere ihre aus
ihrer wortmeldung
außerordentlich weil weil mir sehr daran
gelegen war die feststellung zu treffen
dass wir jetzt über diesen einsatz und
den typus dieses einsatzes in diesem
haus einen konsens haben was die
verfassungsrechtlichen und
völkerrechtlichen grundlagen anbelangt
ich habe ja eben die passage zitiert die
exakt dieselbe passage ist wie in der
wii wie die bundesregierung in den
früheren mandaten formuliert hat
und die haben sie früher abgelehnt ich
könnte auch es sogar ausdrücklich
vorlesen was sie wie sie dort formuliert
haben und jetzt stimmen sie dieser
passage zu sie können herr kollege
trittin nicht gleichzeitig ausdrücklich
expressis verbis in einem antrag der
bundesregierung diesen einsatz für
verfassungs rechtskonform und
völkerrechtskonform erklären und
gleichzeitig hier ihre bedenken was die
contrexx konformität anbelangt zu
protokoll geben entweder oder entweder
ist es rechtmäßig oder es ist nicht
recht muss
und dieser zweifel stört mich weil die
argumente die sie vortragen
scheinargumente sind sie sagen wir haben
ja jetzt eine evaluierungs klauseln da
drin das heißt wir werden evaluieren wir
was es mit diesem auf mit diesem einsatz
auf sich hat wenn sie diesen einsatz für
völkerrechtswidrig halten dann wird er
auch nicht rechtmäßig dadurch dass sie
ein völker einen völkerrechtswidrigen
einsatz evaluieren evaluieren macht
nicht rechtmäßig wenn es
völkerrechtswidrig ist es
völkerrechtswidrig dann wird er auch der
evaluierung nicht rechtmäßig
das ist eindeutig und
die beschränkung auf syrien ist nicht
relevant für die ablehnung gewesen die
sie vorgetragen haben ich zitiere jetzt
mal aus einer stadt kollege aber runden
sich jetzt bitter stunde ist mit diesem
zitat ab
aus den grünen den spitzen der grünen
der die ablehnung wurde wurde begründet
wie folgt der mangelnde einsatz für ein
un-mandat spiegelt der mangelnde einsatz
für ein nun ändern das gibt es immer
noch nicht spiegelt eine geringschätzung
von uno und völkerrecht wieder der wir
als grüne oft keinen fall entgegen
kommen dürfen deutschland kann die un
die uno international stärken indem es
gegenüber den bündnispartnern deutlich
macht dass ohne mandat nichts geht es
immer noch die lage heute
zusammenfassend position der grünen an
erfordert rechtswidriges vorgehen ist
immer auch verfassungswidrig da es hier
eine klare bindung an das grundgesetz
gibt das haben sie verändert ich finde
es positiv dass sie mit der heutigen
beschlussfassung ihrer kurs wechseln wir
begrüßen das außerordentlich und sie
sollten dazu stehen was sie beschließen
[Applaus]
so das haben wir jetzt
ausgetragen und jetzt erhält das wort
für die spd-fraktion tatsächlich ist
seine erste rede im deutschen bundestag
michael müller
vielen dank frau präsidentin meine damen
und herren dieser antrag diese dieser
tagesordnungspunkt ist alles andere als
politische routine und ich verstehe alle
mitglieder des parlaments die immer
wieder kritisch hinterfragen auf welcher
grundlage können wir unsere bundeswehr
in auslandseinsätze schicken und auch
ich teile die position dass ein
militärisches engagement unseres landes
nie eine selbstverständlichkeit sein
darf sondern immer im einzelfall geprüft
und im einzelfall entschieden werden
muss meine damen und herren es gibt auch
dass es unstrittig auch durch unsere an
und durch unser engagement erfolge gegen
den esc er konnte zurückgedrängt werden
er hat nicht mehr die kraft der letzten
jahre aber er ist immer noch nicht noch
längst nicht besiegt immer wieder
erneute terroranschläge machen das
deutlich insbesondere anschläge unter
denen auch die zivilbevölkerung leidet
und ich glaube meine damen und herren
ein terror der auch schnell wieder bei
uns eine rolle spielen kann dieses
morgen zu beenden das darf man nicht auf
halber strecke aufgeben sondern wir
sollten uns auch deswegen weiter
engagieren auch um die irakischen kräfte
vor ort weiter zu befähigen aus eigener
kraft in den auseinandersetzung mit dem
wir es zu bestehen ausbildung zb in die
sicherheitsstrukturen sind wichtig und
müssen fortgesetzt werden
insbesondere auch an den stellen wo es
durch die korona zeit nicht so umgesetzt
werden konnte wie ursprünglich geplant
ein zweiter wesentlicher punkte die
zustimmung hier heute allen ermöglichen
sollte ist doch der einsatz der
humanitären hilfe über drei milliarden
euro wurden inzwischen eingesetzt für
wasserversorgung gesundheitsversorgung
für bildungsangebote für dinge also für
infrastruktur um die situation vor ort
zu stabilisieren um der bevölkerung
konkret zu helfen und das wiederum ist
ein fundament auch in zukunft für
staatliche souveränität und
eigenverantwortung des irak diese
humanitäre hilfe ein wesentlicher ansatz
unseres engagement
meine damen und herren ein dritter punkt
ähnlich ergehen wie der wichtig es für
unsere zustimmung ist dass dieser
einsatz gewünscht ist ja wir haben die
un wir haben die resolution des
sicherheitsrates aber wir haben vor
allen dingen den wunsch auch der
irakischen regierung die beiden
ministerinnen außenministerin und
verteidigungsministerin haben das
eindrucksvoll
vor 14 tagen hier bestätigt dass sie
auch frau lamprecht bei ihrem besuch vor
ort genau damit konfrontiert worden ist
dass die irakische regierung erwartet
dass sich die bundesrepublik weiter
engagiert genauso im übrigen wie auch
unsere bündnispartner vor ort wir
befinden uns in dem kampf gegen den
terror in einer internationalen
solidarität in einem internationalen
bündnis vor ort und die kompetenzen der
bundeswehr sind gewünscht und sind
gefordert ob es die luftraumüberwachung
ist die luftbetankung ist und auch
deswegen meine damen und herren glaube
ich ist es dringend geboten dass wir uns
weiter engagieren und ein weiteres halte
ich persönlich auch für einen
entscheidenden punkt das ist das thema
der evaluierung ja wir werden uns diese
koalition hat sich das vorgenommen viel
intensiver mit der frage
auseinandersetzen auf welcher grundlage
engagieren wir uns militärisch wo jetzt
wo in zukunft und vor allen dingen wie
sind diese einsätze gestaltet wir
beginnen auch mit einem
untersuchungsausschuss zum thema
afghanistan wird es das geben mit einer
enquete kommission die das umfassend
auch beleuchtet dieses engagement aber
vor allen dingen dieses mandat irak ist
das erste wonach vielen ankündigungen
der letzten jahre es nun endlich zu dem
punkt kommt wo genau hingeguckt wird ob
das was wir wollen nämlich dieser
vernetzte ansatz
militärisch und humanität zu helfen ob
das den gewünschten erfolg hat und mit
welchen folgen vor ort wir dort auch
tätig sind meine damen und herren das
ist nicht alles einfach ein weiter so
sondern der verlängerungs zeitraum um
neun monate auch die veränderung des
einsatzgebietes ohne syrien eben und vor
allen dingen auch diese intensive
evaluierung das inhaltliche hinterfragen
unseres ansatzes ist eine völlig neue
qualität das ist nicht scheinheilig und
das wird nicht gemacht um den grünen
über eine zustimmung hier zu helfen
sondern herr kollege rücken das wird
gemacht weil es schlichtweg
verantwortungsbewusst es immer wieder
kritisch zu hinterfragen welcher
grundlage eine
damen und herren es
zeichnet sich ja zum glück wie ich finde
mich freut das sehr hier im haus ist auf
zwei fraktionen doch eine breite
mehrheit ab für die zustimmung zum
antrag der bundesregierung und ich
glaube dass das ein wichtiges signal
dieses parlamentes ist ein wichtiges
signal in richtung unserer
bündnispartner ein richtiger ein
wichtiges signal sicherlich auch für den
irak und die verantwortlichen vor ort
selbst vor allen dingen meine damen und
herren aber auch für unsere bevölkerung
und für die soldatinnen und soldaten
das sind männer und frauen unserer
bundeswehr eine parlamentsarmee
die vor ort hervorragende arbeit leistet
und die wie ich finde ihn gerade auch
als parlamentsarmee wenn wir sie in so
ein einsatz schicken eine breite
unterstützung dieses hauses verdient die
spd fraktion wird diesem antrag der
bundesregierung zustimmen vier
unternehmen
michael müller war dass wir hier
angekündigt mit seiner ersten rede im
bundestag natürlich hat er schon viele
reden gehalten er war bis vor kurzem
regierender bürgermeister
von berlin und es jetzt aber im
bundestag recht neu als abgeordnete
gerold otten spricht jetzt für die afg
fraktion erst mitglied des
verteidigungsausschusses
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen das vorliegende
mandatstext ist ein offensichtlicher
formelkompromiss der links gelben
koalition
zeugt von ignoranz ideologie und
selbstbetrug den ignoriert die
machtverhältnisse in syrien ignoriert
dass eigentlich die agieren des nato
partners türkei ignoriert den einfluss
des iran und der iranischen milizen in
der region und er ignoriert die
irakische zerrissenheit ist alles in
folgen in der islamischer konflikte und
westliche interventionen die haben die
koalitionäre hingegen sind sich aber
wieder einmal einig für das gute
einzutreten und der vernetzte ansatz
wird wieder als problemlösung
angepriesen diese kritisierte politik
wird nun schon seit jahren von
wechselnden koalitionen verfolgt
allerdings immer ohne erfolg
so versteigt sich nun die unionsfraktion
trotz des scheiterns in afghanistan zu
der behauptung deutschland wird an
euphrat und tigris verteidigt und stimmt
die mandat kritiklos zu
das grundübel das vorliegende mandats
ist jedoch nicht aus der welt für grünen
gewissensberuhigung muss es eben
verschleiert werden syrien ist nicht
mehr einsatzgebiet des mandats counter
das existiert aber weiterhin ein
deutlicher selbstbetrug im angesichts
der zuvor vertretenen positionen als
hier im oktober 2020 auch dass der heute
noch gültige mandat zur verlängerung
anstand sprach der grüne abgeordnete
tobias lindner heute staatsminister im
auswärtigen amt davon dass das mandat
nicht nur völkerrechtswidrig sei sondern
auch ein untaugliches mittel wäre aber
betankt das deutsche tankflugzeug nicht
weiterhin französische und amerikanische
kampfflugzeuge die anschließende
völkerrechtswidrige einsatz für ihn
fliegen
diese fragen was sie sich bei den grünen
beantworten denn sie von den grünen die
bis zur wahl so vehement gegen den krieg
einer koalition der willigen mit
deutscher beteiligung waren sie
unterstützung genau das was sie zuvor
zutiefst abgelehnt haben den einsatz
gegen counter day und ein beispiel der
grünen schizophrenie haben wir in dem
der frage gerade eben bekommen bei den
innovationen von kollegen trittin
wir sind dann auch nicht so vergesslich
wie die fdp die nato trainingsmission im
irak unter das kinn ihr es in syrien
sind nach wie vor zwei aufträge in einem
mandat
zwei aufträge die sowohl geografisch wie
auch methodisch voneinander
unterschiedliche ziele verfolgen
da gehört das mandat erteilt das wussten
sie von fdp in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode noch sehr gut und sie
haben das seit 2010 bei jedem
mandatsverlängerung gefordert
nun sind sie in der regierung wird
hätten die bundestag doch über beide
aufträge getrennt abstimmen lassen
können aber das wäre wohl nicht so im
sinne der grünen gewesen
hier opfern sie von der fdp bereitwillig
ihre überzeugung für den links gelten
koalitionsfrieden
meine damen und herren das mandat muss
geteilt werden geteilt damit wir über
luft betanken und luftraumüberwachung so
wie wir die trainingsmission mir sagt
getrennt abstimmen können es
bedauerlicherweise nicht geschehen daher
legen wir das mandat ab vielen dank
vielen dank
nächster redner in dieser debatte wird
ulrich lechte seine sitzt für die fdp
und ausschuss für auswärtige politik und
40 auch hier zum bundeswehreinsatz im
irak
[Applaus]
offensichtlich größer geworden sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das gerade die
afg von schizophrenie im hause spricht
also sorry to say aber ihr seid hier
immer der kasperle verein der
unterschiedlichsten sachen vorträgt und
uns hier wirklich
mehr als amüsierte manchen bereichen und
gerade der kollege otten dass sie weder
reden hier vortragen die vermutlich gar
nicht ihre meinungen entsprechend tut
mir leid das ist das ist die
schizophrenie die eigentliche aber bitte
der anlass und sagen wir sie morgen in
diesem einsatz planen die abscheulichen
verbrechen der terrororganisation
islamischer staat im irak und syrien
seit 2014 und die erst terroristen haben